SORRY WE'RE RUNNING LATE TODAY
BUT TOO MANY THINGS TO DO AND
NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE TO DO IT
OBVIOUSLY.
SURE MOST OF YOU KNOW THAT --
BUT I WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO THE
MEETING OF SELF FIVE BUT THIS OF
FIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
OF FOR APRIL THE EIGHTH -- HERE
AT THE CAPITOL -- WHEN ASKED WE
CALL THE ROLL BECAUSE I THINK WE
HAVE A QUORUM?
WEBER HERE CHAIR OF JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
GREAT WE HAVE A QUORUM OF THE
FIRST ITEM ON THE AGENDA TODAY
IS ITEM EIGHT TWENTY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE WITH US TODAY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
OF PUBLIC HEALTHIER.
WAS THERE YEAH.
GOOD.
OF WHO'S WITH US TODAY.
ATTORNEY GENERAL [inaudible]
WELCOME.
VENTURE MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WAIT TO BE WITH YOU.
ALL MINE YES IT'S ALL YOURS
THANK YOU.
LET ME BEGIN BY SAYING TO EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
WITH MY DEPARTMENT.
AND AND MY TEAM -- WE HAVE BEEN
BUSY OVER THIS PAST YEAR AND WE
FORTUNATE BEEN ABLE TO DO A
NUMBER OF THINGS ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE.
SO IF I CAN'T GIVEN THE THE TIME
MIGHT BE A LITTLE CONSTRAINT I'M
JUST GOING TO SOME OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THE WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING RECAP.
SOME OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR UNIV
SIR CERTAINLY COURSE AFTER I
FINISH UP. TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
OR THIS IN ANY COMMENTS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. TWENTY EIGHTEEN ERA
OUR BUREAU OF FORENSIC SERVICES
WELL WE TESTED TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE
KITS WE ARE UP TO DATE WE HAVE
NO BACKLOG.
I WE CONTINUE TO DO OTHER WORK
WE SOLVE MURDERS WE CONTINUE TO
IDENTIFY VICTIMS ESPECIALLY FOR
EXAMPLE OF OUR RECENT FIRES THE
CAMPFIRE.
A AND SO FORTH OUR FORENSIC
SERVICES TEAM -- PROVIDES
FORENSICS WORK TO IDENTIFY
EVIDENCE NECESSARY FOR
PROSECUTION FOR MOST OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PROSECUTORIAL
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WE DO SO MAD CHAIR I WANNA
REMIND EVERYONE WITHOUT CHARGE
TO YOUR POLICE DEPARTMENTS TO
YOUR SHARES DEPARTMENTS TO YOUR
PROSECUTORS.
MOST OF THEM EXCEPT FOR THOSE IN
THE BIG CITIES IN AND THE COUNTY
THAT CAN AFFORD TO HAVE THEIR
OWN FORENSIC SERVICES.
WHERE THE -- AGENCY OF FIRST
RESORT IF WE DON'T DO IT FOR
THEM THEN YOUR FOLKS IN LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE TO PAY FOR
IT SOMEWHERE ELSE AND IT A FAR
HIGHER COST.
WE ALSO HAPPEN TO HAVE THE
PREMIER FORENSIC -- TEAM IN THE
NATION EXCEPT PERHAPS FOR THE
FEDS OUR SHOP DOES THE MOST AND
THE BEST WORK AROUND THE NATION.
OUR BUREAU OF FIREARMS AGENTS
WHILE THEY CONTINUE TO DISARM
DANGEROUS INDIVIDUALS.
ARE IN A JOINT OPERATION LAST
FALL FOR EXAMPLE WORKING WITH
THE LA SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
OUR AGENTS RETRIEVED SEVEN
ASSAULT WEAPONS FIFTY SIX HAND
GUNS TWENTY ONE SHOT GUNS FORTY
AB SORRY TWENTY FOUR RIFLES.
AND THREE LOWER RECEIVERS WHICH
ARE PART OF OTHER FIREARM.
IN ADDITION WE SEIZED ALONG WITH
THOSE OCT THAT CASH OF WEAPONS
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION FIFTY HIGH CAPACITY
MAGAZINE WHICH I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE TODAY.
ARE NOT LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR AND WE PREVAILED RECENTLY IN
A LAWSUIT DEALING WITH THE
CENSUS TRYING TO AVOID.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ADDING A
QUESTION ABOUT CITIZENSHIP WHICH
AS YOU KNOW WOULD CUT BECAUSE IN
AT UNDER COUNT.
AND AS WE ARE ALL WE'RE VERY
WELL AWARE AN UNDERCOUNT COULD
COST NOT JUST.
MONEY BUT ALSO REPRESENTATION
QUICK EXAMPLE NINETEEN NINETY WE
HAD AN UNDERCOUNTER JUST HI TWO
POINT 74%.
THE RESULT WE LOST A
CONGRESSIONAL SEAT IN THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES AND WE LOST A
TENS IF NOT HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IT'S RESULT THAT
THAT'S THAT TARA.
UNDERCOUNT TWO POINTS 74% WE
DON'T WANT EXPERIENCE THAT AGAIN
BECAUSE WE DESERVE TOHAVE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER DOLLARS
RETURN TO CALIFORNIA.
AND WE WANT TO HAVE EVERY SINGLE
SEAT IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES THAT OUR STATE
DESERVES A FOUR FORTY MILLION.
PEOPLE.
ARE WE SECURED HISTORIC AND IN
SOME CASES A EXTREMELY X.
SICKENING PICKET SETTLEMENTS OUR
OFFICE FROM SOME OF THE BIGGEST
NAMES IN AMERICA -- HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FROM
WELLS FARGO A HUNDRED NINETEEN
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS.
A HUNDRED TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FROM BRITISH PETROLEUM ENERGY
COMPANY SEVENTY EIGHT A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS FROM FIAT
CHRYSLER.
CONTINUED NAY MORE.
WE CHALLENGE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THE LAWFUL
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
CONDITIONS IN TRYING TO DEPRIVE
OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENTS.
AGENCIES OF JAG FUNDING FOR
THEIR PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL.
ARE THAT RESULTED IN RETRIEVING
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
TODAY AS A RESULT OF OUR LEGAL
WORK AS WELL RELATED TO
IMMIGRATION MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND
DREAMERS.
HAVE COMPLETED THEIR DOCTOR
RENEWAL WHICH IF YOU RECALL --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
CALL FOR THE REPEAL OF THAT
PROGRAM SO CLOSE.
TO EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY CONTINUE
TO HAVE DOCTOR PROTECTION AS
RESULT OF THE LAWSUIT THAT WE
FILED.
OUR WE HAVE HELD MORE THAN A
SEVEN PUBLIC FORUMS AND MEETINGS
WITH.
OUR STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO HEAR THEIR REMARKS AND
COMMENTS REGARDING THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
WHICH YOU ALL PASSED IN A
LANDMARK ACTION BECAUSE NO OTHER
STATE OR EVEN FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
PROVIDES THAT TYPE OF PROTECTION
FOR CONSUMERS OVER THE INTERNET
AND NOW IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING
TO PREPARE FOR THAT RULE MAKING.
WE'RE FIGHTING IN COURT TO
DEFEND CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN CAR
STANDARDS ARE THOSE THAT ARE A
MODEL NOW FOR THE REST THE
NATION.
ARE THEY ARE -- MIMIC CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS AND THEY ARE NOW
NATIONAL STANDARDS THAT WERE
HERE TO FIGHT TO PROTECT THOSE
NATIONAL STANDARDS.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING THROUGH THE
TAX RECOVERY AN UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY A TEAM THAT WE HAVE TO
GO AFTER BUSINESSES THAT DON'T
PLAY BY THE RULES THEY DON'T PAY
THEIR WORKERS THE RIGHT SALARIES.
THEY DON'T COVER THEM WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WORKER'S
COMPENSATION THEY DON'T PAY
STATE TAXES.
AND IS RESULT THEY ARE MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR OTHERS TO DO PLAY
BY THE RULES AS BUSINESSES TO
COMPETE.
ARE WE BROUGHT IN ABOUT SIX AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALONE.
ARE WE BUSTED OPERATION IN THE
BAY AREA CALLED RAINBOW BRITE IT
WAS A SUPPOSEDLY AN ADULT AND
CHILD CARE FACILITY PROVIDING
CARE FOR ADULTS AND ALSO FOR
CHILDREN.
THEY WERE ALSO HAPPY THEY ALSO
HAPPEN TO BE RAINY --
TRAFFICKING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
RING WHERE THEY WERE ESSENTIALLY
KEEPING PEOPLE GET CLOSE TO
SLAVE WAGES -- IN SOME CASES
THEY WERE TRAFFICKING SOME OF
THE EMPLOYEES FOR SEX -- WE WERE
ABLE TO BUST THEM THROUGH THE
WORK OF THE TAX RECOVERY AN
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY TEAM AND WE
ALSO HAPPEN TO FIND FIREARMS
INCLUDING RIGHT THERE IN THE
CHILD CARE CENTER.
THAT WERE HELD BY THESE FOLKS
WE'RE LEAD A COALITION AS YOU
KNOW OF TWENTY ONE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. TO FIGHT TO PROTECT THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IT IS THE
WORK THAT WE ARE DOING.
AS THE EADER TOURNEY'S IN THAT
CASE THAT WILL KEEP THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT GOING
PROTECT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE MILLION AMERICANS WHO HAVE
A PRE EXISTING MEDICAL CONDITION
WHO COULD LOSE THAT IF --IF
THIS CASE WERE GOING THE WRONG
DIRECTION IN THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT WOULD BE REPEALED TO THE
COURTS AND SO WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
PROTECT THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO NOW HAVE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE AS A RESULT OF
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
AND THE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S
WITH PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS OR
WHO HAVE KIDS WHO ARE UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY SIX WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEIR FAMILIES WITH
HEALTHCARE.
FINALLY I'LL JUST MENTION OF
SOME OF OUR BUDGET REQUESTS THAT
ARE A PENDING.
OUR ON THE APPS PROGRAM THE ARE
PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM PROGRAM --
WE HOPE THAT YOU'LL LOOK AT THIS
VERY CLOSELY BECAUSE FOR THE
FIRST TIME WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
THE RESOURCES THAT IT IT WILL
TAKE AND WE HOPE NOT BASED ON
LIMITED TERM APPOINTMENT BUT I'M
PERMANENT POINT IS.
ACTUALLY LET IT BECOME MORE
AGGRESSIVE ARE THE GOVERNOR
AGREED WITH US THAT WE SHOULD
STOP TAKING MONEY OUT OF A
SPECIAL FUND ACCOUNTS TO TRY.
TO COVER THE COST OF THIS
BECAUSE IT DEPRIVES THE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE OPERA
SUPPOSED TO BE PAID FOR BY THE
SPECIAL FUNDS.
THE TYPE OF SERVICES REQUIRED
AND SO -- WE SHOULD NOT BE
TAKING MONEY TO HELP FOLKS TO
GROUP WHEN IT RESPONSIBLY ON
WEAPONS.
TAKE MONEY AWAY FROM THAT
PURPOSE SO THEY CAN REGISTER
THEM STAY LICENSE AND SO FORTH --
SO FOR THE PURPOSE OF HELPING --
APPREHEND THOSE WHO ARE
ILLEGALLY IN POSSESSION OF
WEAPONS AND SO THEY SHOULD HELP
US -- IT TAKES A LONG WAY I
SHOULD MENTION AS WELL THAT THE
THE BUREAU OF FORENSIC SERVICES --
IT NOW WILL BE ABLE TO GET FROM
UNDER THE THE WHOLE IT WAS IN
BECAUSE OF LOSS OF MONEY THAT
WAS COMING INTO THE DNA ID FUND
AS A RESULT PROP. FORTY SEVEN
YOU MAY RECALL WE ARE NOW
RECEIVING LESS MONEY INTO THE
DNA ID FUND WHICH MEANS -- FEWER
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE THE FORENSIC
SERVICES WE WERE EITHER FACING
HAVING TO CUT FORENSIC SERVICES
WOULD MEAN WHICH WOULD MEAN
CUTTING.
FORENSIC SERVICES FOR A LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES OR
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THAT THE GOVERNOR CAME THROUGH
AND HAS HELPED US NOW TRY TO GET
THAT.
ON OF OUR FIRM FOOTING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WHICH I'VE EXPRESSED
IN THE PAST.
CALIFORNIA'S GROUND ZERO FOR
THAT THERE'S NO STATE THAT HAS --
HIGHER LEVELS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FOR SEX FOR LABOR
THE CALIFORNIA WE'RE TRYING TO
INCREASE OUR ACTIVITY THERE
WORKING WITH OUR FEDERAL AND
LOCAL PARTNERS TO GO AFTER THAT
BECAUSE TRULY THE VICTIMS ARE
JUST THE FOLKS.
WHO LOSE THEIR FAMILY MEMBER TO
SIX TRAFFIC IT'S THE FOR THOSE
WHO ARE BETTER BEANS TRAFFIC IT
WHO ARE THE BIGGEST VICTIMS IT'S
WERE TRYING TO DEAL WITH THAT AS
WELL?
OUR FINALLY I JUST MENTION A
COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS THAT I I
HOPE YOU'LL KEEP INTO A I TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT.
WHEN WE HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
MOVE FORWARD WE'RE ABLE TO MOVE
AGGRESSIVELY -- I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR WOMAN HERE IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE BECAUSE WE WERE
LOOKING AT THE CAL GAME PROGRAM
AND CLEARLY THROUGH THE STATE
AUDITOR WE FOUND OUT THERE WERE
SOME.
MAJOR FLAWS IN THE SYSTEM.
AND WE WERE HOPING TO TRY TO
CURE THAT BUT WITHOUT RESOURCES
WOULD BE DIFFICULT -- THIS
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED US WITH
RESOURCES SO NOW WE'RE TACKLING
THAT AND WE'RE HOPING TO SOON BE
ABLE TO COME OUT WITH A SCRUB OF
A CAL GAINES PROGRAM SO THAT.
PEOPLE WHO ARE GONNA BE
CLASSIFIED ARE CLASSIFIED THE
JET BUT THE NOT IN HARM CAN IN.
VIOLATION OF THEIR RIGHTS SO
THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT HAVE THE
DOLLARS TO DO THAT WE'RE NOW AT
THE SAME TIME ALONG THE SAME
LINES TRY TO MONITOR MODERNIZE
OUR FIREARM IT SYSTEMS SO WE CAN
BE MORE EFFECTIVE WHETHER IT'S
WITH THE APP'S PROGRAM.
OR MAKING SURE THAT THOSE WHO
ARE LAWFULLY REGISTRY WEAPONS
AND RESPONSIBLY TAKING CARE OF
THOSE WEAPONS THAT THEY WE THEY
ARE TRACK WELL SO WE DON'T --
FIND OURSELVES -- TRACKING THEM
FOR THE WRONG REASONS ARE WE'RE
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
AS HE CCPA. FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AS WE TRY TO WRITE THE RAGS.
ARE WE TRYING TO MANAGE A
REGISTRATION OF KNOWN SEX
OFFENDER TO TO THIS NEW TIERED
SYSTEM WHICH IS A A BEAR OF A
TASK BECAUSE WE'VE NEVER DONE
THIS.
AND WE CAN'T GET THAT ONE WRONG
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PROTECT PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT.
WHO ARE THE LOWER LEVEL
OFFENDERS TO STOP BE CLASSIFIED
AS THE MOST EGREGIOUS SEXUAL
OFFENDERS BUT WE NEED TO GET IT
RIGHT WE DON'T WANT TO PUT
SOMEONE THE WRONG CATEGORY?
BECAUSE THAT REALLY DOES AFFECT
NOT JUST THERE RIGHT BUT THE
RIGHTS OF A CALIFORNIA TO WANT
TO BE SAFE FROM OP PREDATORS WHO
ARE SIX TRAFFICKERS.
I WISH YOU THE SEX OFFENDERS
FINALLY I WANT TO THANKS OF THE
THE LEGISLATURE IN THIS REGARD
BECAUSE THERE WAS THIS ISSUE
WITH THE WITH WHAT I CALL THE
FIFTY FIFTY RAFFLE.
THESE THIS IS THE MAJOR LEAGUE
SPORT SPORTING EVENT RAFFLE
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS SOMEBODY
SPORTING TEAMS THAT WHOLE
RAFFLES DURING THEIR GAMES.
AND THERE WAS SOME TALK OF
TRYING TO EXTEND THIS NOW MAKING
A PERMANENT PROGRAM.
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT
TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE WE'VE
NEVER HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
AUDIT.
AND IT'S BECAUSE WE NEVER HAD
THE RESOURCES TO DO THE ODDITY.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT WE ARE NOW
GONNA -- INCREASE THE FEES THAT
WE CHARGE THOSE WANTED TO THE
RAFFLES SO WE CAN ACTUALLY GO ON
AND DO THE ODDITY SO THEY'RE
GONNA PAY A FEE SO THEY CAN DO
THE ARE -- THEIR RAFFLES AND
THAT WAS A GREAT WAY TO RESOLVE
THIS SO WE NOW CAN ACTUALLY TELL
YOU REPORT BACK TO IN THE NEXT
COMING YEARS.
ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT'S BENEFITING CALIFORNIANS
ARE NOT.
THE FINAL THING I THINK I'LL SAY
IN THOSE THESE LAST UPDATES IS.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU COULD
DO NECESSARILY RIGHT AWAY BUT IT
IS SOMETHING THAT IS BECOMING
MORE AND MORE OF AN ISSUE AND
THAT IS.
COMPETITIVE SALARIES -- I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW TOUGH IT IS TO
ATTRACT THE MANY WOMEN IT TAKES
TO RETRIEVE WEAPONS FROM FELONS
WHO ARE POSSESSING THEM AGAINST
THE LAW.
WHEN OUR AGENTS GET PAID FAR
LESS THAN AGENTS IN OUR OFFICERS
AND CIVIL CLASSIFICATIONS ARE
AGENTS ALL IN THE IN THE APPS
PROGRAM THE FIREARMS PROGRAM?
THEY ALL HAVE TO HAVE COLLEGE
DEGREES.
THERE AGENCIES THAT DON'T
REQUIRE COLLEGE DEGREES YET THEY
PAY THEIR OFFICERS AND AGENTS
MORE THAT WE GET TO PAY OUR
FOLKS. TO SOME OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS WORK I COULD SAY THE
SAME THING ABOUT OUR LEGAL
SECRETARIES WERE WORKING WITH
ATTORNEYS AGASSI THE SINGLE
SAVING ABOUT OUR OUR ATTORNEYS.
WE PAY OUR HIGHEST MOST TRAINED
AND TALENTED ATTORNEYS WITH THE
MOST EXPERIENCE.
AROUND THE SAME AMOUNT THAT A
PRESTIGIOUS LAW FIRM PAYS.
A FIRST YEAR.
LAWYER OUT OF LAW SCHOOL -- IT'S
JUST.
IT'S TOUGH AND I KNOW THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THE LEGISLATURE
CAN'T DEAL WITH DIRECTLY BECAUSE
IT'S MOSTLY OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
AND WORK WITH CAL HR -- HUMAN
RESOURCES TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
BUT IT BECOMES REALLY DIFFICULT
WHEN YOU ARE GOOD ABOUT GIVING
ME RESOURCES THE HIGHER UP TO
DEAL WITH APPS FOR TO DEAL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT.
REGULATIONS.
BUT I CAN'T GET TELL THE PEOPLE
TO WORK BECAUSE IT'S TOUGH FOR
THEM TO LEAVE WHAT THEY'VE GOT.
AND TAKE A PAY CUT TO COME AND
DO IT SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
HAVING JUST PAID ATTENTION TO
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS BECAUSE I
THINK IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
THAT THE MEN AND WOMEN.
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
CAN RIGHTLY SAY THAT THEY ARE
THE BEST IN THE LAND WHEN IT
COMES TO PROVIDING JUSTICE.
IN A CALIFORNIA A DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND IT'S A PLEASURE TO
WORK WITH THEM AND IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU.
VENTURA TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM
[inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- MR
TRAIN JOURNAL I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU THAT I'M SURE
YOU'RE ANTICIPATING -- BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN YOUR
OFFICE HOURS FOR TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN ORDER TO DEAL
WITH THE APP'S BACKLOG AND WE
WERE ASSURED THAT THAT WOULD
TAKE CARE OF THE PROBLEM.
AND THEN THREE SO.
TWO THIRTEEN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN IN THE BUDGET YOU WERE
GIVEN FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
TAKE CARE OF THE APPS BACKLOG
AND YET THE NUMBERS WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN AS THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
WHO ARE IN POSSESSION OF AN
ILLEGAL FIREARM HAS INCREASED IT
HASN'T DECREASED AND I
THROUGHOUT YOUR TESTIMONY I KEEP
HEARING YOU SAY?
THINGS LIKE YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE
GIVEN THE RESOURCES THAT WE NEED
WERE SO MUCH BETTER ABLE TO DO
OUR JOB WELL WE'VE BEEN GIVING.
YOUR OFFICE RESOURCES.
SEVERAL TIMES AND YOU'RE NOT
GETTING THE JOB DONE.
SO I AGREE WITH YOU THAT THE MEN
AND WOMEN AND DOJ OR DOING A
PHENOMENAL JOB.
A DIFFICULT JOB OFTENTIMES
PARTICULARLY IN TRYING TO
RETRIEVE WEAPONS FROM PEOPLE WHO
PROBABLY DON'T WANT TO GIVE THEM
UP THAT'S NOT THE CASE ALL THE
TIME MY CONCERN IS HOW THE
DEPARTMENT IS BEING MANAGED.
IS THE ATTENTION ON WHAT THE MEN
AND WOMEN IN THE DOJ NEED TO DO
THAT THE LEGISLATURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE THE TAXPAYERS HAVE
GIVEN. TO THIS DEPARTMENT OR IS
THE ATTENTION ON OTHER THINGS
PERHAPS AT A FEDERAL LEVEL.
THAT IS DISTRACTING YOU SO CAN
YOU ANSWER PLEASE WHY WE'VE
GIVEN ALL THIS MONEY AND YET
THIS BACKLOG HAS INCREASED.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DO LOVE TO GIVE
YOU SOME OF THE INFORMATION AND
WE CAN PROVIDE YOU WITH -- SOME
FACT SHEETS AND ALSO THE REPORT --
THAT GOES INTO SOME OF THE APPS
PROGRAM ACTIVITY AND HISTORY --
I BECAUSE I THINK IT'S WORTH
READING.
FIRST I SHOULD TELL YOU THAT WE
DID A DEEP DIVE ON THE APPS
PROGRAM BECAUSE WE HEARD MANY OF
THE MEMBERS CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
WHY WE STILL HAVE PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE NOT HAD THEIR WEAPONS
RETRIEVED EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T
HAVE A RIGHT TO TO POSSESS IT?
AND SO I ASKED MY TEAM TO DO A
DEEP DIVE SO WE GET BACK TO YOU
SO LET ME TELL YOU SOME OF THE
FACT THAT WE FOUND OUT.
FIRST IS A TWENTY NINETEEN NOT
TWENTY THIRTEEN IT'S A IT'S A
DIFFERENT DAY AND IT'S A
DIFFERENT PROGRAM QUITE HONESTLY
FROM WHAT IT WAS IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN ARE FOR THEM TO
GIVE YOU A QUICK EXAMPLE JUST
EXPLAIN THAT IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
WE WERE GIVEN A NUMBER OF
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS.
WITH THE MONEY THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED TO HIRE FOLKS.
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE IT'S TOUGH
ENOUGH TO HIRE SOMEONE TO COME
TO WORK FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AS A SPECIAL AGENT TO
SOME OF THE MOST DIFFICULT AND
DANGEROUS WORK AROUND.
IT'S EVEN MORE DIFFICULT WE TELL
THEM AND BY THE WAY I CAN ONLY
HIRE YOU FOR A YEAR.
AND SO A LOT OF THOSE POSITIONS
WENT UNFILLED AND AS A RESULT
SOME OF THE MONEY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY GAVE TO THE
PARTNER JUSTICE BY THE WAY
BEFORE I GOT HERE.
NEVER GOT SPENT ANY GOT RETURNED
RIGHT AND SO IT WAS IT YOU YOU
ALLOCATED A CERTAIN AMOUNT.
BUT IT NEVER GOT USED SOME OF IT
DIDN'T GET USED FOR FOR RELIGION
IT RAISES WE COULDN'T HIGHER.
UP FOR SOME OF THE POSITIONS
THAT YOU PROVIDED US BECAUSE
THEY WERE LIMITED TERM.
CHECK I CAN I'M SORRY CAN I STOP
YOU THERE IF YOU DON'T MIND
MADAM CHAIR BECAUSE WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE OF THE MONEY
WAS REQUESTED.
AND THIS THE BODY WAS ASSURED.
THAT THAT MONEY WOULD BE MORE
THAN SUFFICIENT TO DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE AT HAND AND IT WASN'T SO
WHETHER OR NOT YOU WERE THERE IT
DOESN'T MATTER IT'S THE SAME
DEPARTMENT.
I AGREE WITH THAT.
BUT IT'S HARD FOR ME.
TO RESPOND TO SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED WITHOUT A WIN IT WASN'T
MY WATCH BUT I WILL TELL YOU THE
NIGHT AND I SYMPATHIZE WITH YOU
ON THAT I'VE BEEN IN THAT
POSITION I DO THINK HOWEVER --
YOUR LAST STOP NOW SO BACKSTOPS
WOULD BE THE BUCK STOPS WITH YOU
AND I JUST.
I WHEN HERE SOMEWHERE IN YOUR
COMMENTS SOME REASSURANCE THAT
THIS TIME.
THE JOB WILL GET DONE BECAUSE IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE WERE
TOLD THE JOB WOULD GET DONE AND
GET DONE IN THANK.
YOU VAST YOU'VE NOT ONLY BE
ASKED THE OF UNDER IS QUESTION
YOU YOU VESTED IN A A VERY
HONEST WAY.
AND SO I WANT TO TRY TO GIVE YOU
ES HONEST ANSWERS I CAN.
OKAY FEEL FREE ARE BECAUSE THIS
WAS IMPORTANT.
WHEN WE DID THE DEEP DIVE THIS
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
FOUND [inaudible] ONE THE
WORKLOAD CONTINUES TO INCREASE.
TO THE HIRING HASN'T GONE AS
QUICKLY AS MAYBE IT WAS
REPRESENT I CAN'T TELL YOU BUT
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN PEOPLE
THOUGHT MAYBE THIS MONEY WOULD
DO IT.
IT DIDN'T WORK BECAUSE WE
COULDN'T HIGHER UP WITH SOME OF
THE MONEY THAT YOU GAVE US AND
SO WE NEVER GOT STAFFED UP THE
WAY IT WOULD HAVE.
THE NECESSARY TO TRY TO REALLY
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE ENTERING INTO THE APPS
SYSTEM.
SO IT WAS TOUGH TO FINISH THAT
UP BUT THREE AND THIS IS THE ONE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHERE I HOPE EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU WILL PAY
CLOSE ATTENTION.
THE WAY WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO
RETRIEVAL OF THESE WEAPONS.
IS THE NOT THE MOST EFFICIENT
WAY AND EXPLAIN IT REAL QUICKLY.
THE REASON WE CAN PICK UP
WEBPAGES BECAUSE EITHER THERE'S
A PERSON WHOSE A FELON.
HE'S BEEN CONVICTED OR IS
CONVICTED OF OF REALLY
SERIOUSNESS TO ME.
OR HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE A
DANGER TO HIMSELF OR OTHERS
RIGHT MENTALLY. FOR HAS ORDERS
OF DOMESTIC -- RESTRAINING
ORDERS AGAINST PRETTY CLEAR.
AS YOU KNOW SUBSET OF PEOPLE.
HERE'S A DIFFICULTY.
WE WAIT TILL AFTER THEY'VE LEFT
THE COURTHOUSE AFTER THEY'VE
LEFT THE JAIL HOUSE.
AND HAVE YET TURNED IN THE
WEAPON EVEN THOUGH BY LAW THEY
LOST THE RIGHT TO POSSESS THOSE
THE MOMENT.
THEY WE KEEP FELONS -- FOR THE
VIOLATOR THROUGH A CUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE TOWARD.
WE'RE WAITING UNTIL THE LATTER
PART AFTER THEY'VE.
WHEN -- GONE BACK ADDED THE
CALIFORNIA TO TRY TO DOUBT
RETRIEVE THE WEAPON WHICH TAKES
A LOT OF TIME AND QUITE A FEW
MEMBERS MOST OF OUR TEAMS ARE
FORTY SIX MEMBERS.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS WE'RE
GOING AFTER THESE FOLKS.
AT THE BACK AND IS THAT AT THE
FRONT AND SO ONE OF THESE WE
IDENTIFIER REPORT IS A RATHER
THAN WAIT TELLER OUT THERE AGAIN
LOOSE.
BECAUSE THEY SERVE THEIR TIME BY
THE WAY THERE'S TO PROBABLY
UNDER PAROLE BUT THE PAROLE
OFFICERS HAVEN'T SAID A TAKE.
HAS THIS GUY TURNING HIS WEAPON
GET.
GOING OUT THERE DOING TOUCH AS
MANY WE'RE GOING OUT TO THEIR
HOME WE'RE GOING OUT TO THE
RELATIVES WERE GOING TO THE
WORKPLACE TO TRY TO GET THESE
WEAPONS.
HOW ABOUT IF WE TELL THE COURT
BEFORE YOU LET THIS GUY FREE OR
THE PROBATION OFFICERS BEFORE
YOU LET THIS GUY FREE?
CAN WE JUST MAKE SURE THAT THEY
TURN IN THEIR WEAPONS.
THAT HAS BEEN DONE.
UP FRONT SECONDLY THERE ARE
CASES WHERE WE GO AFTER WEBER
FROM SO WE WORKED AT IT FOR
WEEKS THEN WE GO OUT THERE.
AND THEN OFFICE AND WEBER
SEVERAL TIMES TRYING TO LOOK AT
THE PERSON WE FOUND THE DUTIES
OF TALK I TURN THAT WEAPON IN
THREE MONTHS AGO.
WHEN WE SAY WHAT YEAH YEAH I
GIVE IT TO LOCAL?
POLICE DEPARTMENT LOCAL SHERIFF.
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT PLEASE
PART THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO
NOTIFY US WHEN THEY COLLECT THE
WEAPON FROM SOMEONE WHO'S ON THE
APP SYSTEM.
SO WE'VE GOT WELL THE WORK OF
YOU KNOW.
GETTING READY GO AFTER THAT
PERSON.
AND WE FIND OUT THAT THE WEAPONS
IN.
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
COORDINATION WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEN FINALLY.
AND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ONE I
THINK FOR EVERYONE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHO WATCHED WHO
CHEERS FROM YOUR LOCAL FOLKS I
CAN'T WE RETREAT THESE WEAPONS
FASTER.
WE'RE NEVER GOING.
TO STAFF UP ENOUGH TO COVER THE
ENTIRE STATE AND THE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE.
BUT WHAT WE CAN DO IS TRY TO
HAVE A BETTER COORDINATION WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT SO THAT WE
CAN WORK WITH THEM TO COLLECT
ADVENTURE THE CASE THAT LA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WORK
WITH US WHERE WE COLLECTED.
OVER A HUNDRED AND TEN WEAPONS.
HERE THE DIFFICULTY.
LA COUNTY CAN LAUGHTER SOMEBODY
WAS ON APPS INTO THE MOMENT THEY
STEP OVER THE STREET LINE.
THAT NOW BECOMES.
ORANGE COUNTY THEN THEY GOT A
LEGO.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT RESTRICTION
AND SO.
IT'S OFTENTIMES DIFFICULT FOR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT SAY YEAH
WE'RE WE'RE ALL IN TO TRY TO DO
APPS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T THEY
CAN'T GO AFTER SOMEBODY WHO
THESE ARE JURISDICTION.
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS
CREATE A TEAM THAT WORKS WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TRY TO APPREHEND THESE FOLKS AND
WE CAN BE THE GLUE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE TEAMS ARE
WORKING WELL TOGETHER WE HAD A
CASE RECENTLY I THINK WITH
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
AND I THINK IT WAS SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY THE GUY WAS IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY HE SAID -- I GAVE
MY WEAPON AYE AYE MY SISTER HAS
A WEAPON WHERE SHE SHE WAS I
THINK A CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
WE HAD TO SEND ONE OF OUR GUYS.
ALL THE WAY TO THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY TO CHECK THAT OUT.
BY THE TIME HE COULD GET BACK TO
SING REPORT IT WAS.
HOURS AND HOURS OF TIME WHY
CAN'T WE HAVE A COORDINATION
WHERE WE'RE WORKING WITH CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
LA COUNTY THE CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
SO THAT WE CAN DO THIS WORK FOR
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND SO YOUR
QUESTIONS ARE ABSOLUTELY
LEGITIMATE.
BUT I THINK YOU'LL AGREE THAT
WITH THE WORK THAT THESE
OFFICERS AGENTS HAVE DONE.
NEVER ONCE IN ITS MORE THAN TEN
YEAR HISTORY HAS THERE BEEN A
BIT AND A DIFFICULT INCIDENT
WHERE SOMEONE GOT HURT.
AND WE RETREAT TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF WEAPONS I THINK WE WANT TO DO
IS MAKE IT BETTER I'M BRED TO
WORK WITH YOU TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN.
AND I THINK THE GOVERNOR FOR
RECOGNIZING ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
WE CAN DO THAT.
CHENEY A QUESTION MR LACKEY.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE HAVE THE
CHANCE TO INTERACT WITH THE
HIGHEST LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
IN THE STATE SO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE SIR TO
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
OBVIOUSLY.
THE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS A VERY PROLIFIC AND AN
EXTENSIVE IT IN PASSING
LEGISLATION.
WITH COMPLEX GUN REGULATIONS.
AND IF YOU GO TO YOUR WEBSITE
TODAY.
THIS IS WHAT YOU HAVE THE COMES
UP. TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE'S BEEN
QUITE A FEW REGULATIONS THAT --
I'VE BEEN PASSAGE.
TWENTY SIXTEEN IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO BE IN COMPLIANCE.
OF WHICH WERE VERY VERY
[inaudible]
CONCERNED ABOUT.
CONTROLLING -- ACCESS TO WEAPONS
BY THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO USE THEM
IN A DEFENSIVE MANNER -- WE GET
WE STILL HAVE THIS APPS.
SITUATION THAT MY COLLEAGUE.
AND YOU JUST INTERACTED ON SO I
DON'T THINK I NEED TO BEAT THAT.
ANY HARDER -- BUT YOU KNOW.
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND WEAPONS IS
A LOT.
AND IT HAS GROWN TO THE POINT TO
WHERE IT'S EPIDEMIC.
AND VERY THREATENING AND I THINK
THAT -- WE NEED TO JUST DO A
BETTER JOB I UNDERSTAND THE
EXPLANATIONS YOU JUST GAVE AND
I'M NOT HERE TO CHALLENGE THEM.
I'M JUST HERE TO TELL YOU THAT I
I HOPE.
THAT WE CAN FIGURE THIS OUT.
A BETWEEN YOUR AGENCY AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE THIS IS POOR
PERFORMANCE.
JUST PLAINLY STATED THAT'S WHAT
IT IS AND WE CAN EXPLAIN IT AWAY
IN A WAY THAT'S JUST QUITE
FRANKLY UNACCEPTABLE SO.
I'M JUST PRAYING THAT WE CAN
FIGURE THIS OUT AND MAKE IT A
PRIORITY -- IN IN THE DAYS AHEAD
AND THE THE FINAL REMARK THAT I
HAVE HAS TO DO WITH THE YOU MADE
A COMMENT ABOUT THE RAPE KITS
WEIRD SEXUAL SOCKETS.
MORE SENSIBLY STATED -- THERE WE
JUST HAD A RECENT AUDIT THAT WAS
REVIEWED.
AND THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
SAT WITH ME AS WE HEARD.
SOME OF THE REPORTS AND I HAVE
TO SAY THAT -- THE COORDINATION
BETWEEN YOUR AGENCY AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AT THE VERY LEAST IS PROBLEMATIC
AND VERY SCARY -- AND IT'S A
DISSERVICE QUITE HONESTLY
ANOTHER VERY BIG FAILURE.
THAT -- I HOPE THAT.
YOU WOULD SEE IT AS A BIGGER
PRIORITY AS WE ALL DO I MEAN
CLEARLY IT IS OF A HUGE
DISAPPOINTMENT AND AGAIN THERE'S
EXPLANATIONS.
BUT WE JUST GOT TO DO BETTER MAN
BUT I I THINK THAT THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT -- WE
COORDINATE BETTER.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
SEE IT THE SAME WAY.
THE RUMOR FACT BENCH IF I HAVE A
CHANCE TO RESPOND LET ME A LET
ME AGREE WITH YOU APART AND AND
GIVE YOU A DIFFERENT EXPLANATION
IMPORT.
A AYE APPLET AGREE WITH UNITED
STATES STARTED TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS RESPONSE UP EARLIER I
THINK YOU'RE HAS BEFORE BETTER
COORDINATION.
NO DOUBT NO DOUBT BECAUSE YOU'RE
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO BE HERE TO
GIVE ME ENOUGH MONEY TO DO THIS
ON MY OWN.
THEY'RE JUST NOT COULD BE AND
THERE'S NO REASON TO BECAUSE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TOUCHES
SOME OF THESE FOLKS.
BEFORE I DO AND SO WE ACTUALLY
SHOULD CORD.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT IT'S
IT'S I WOULD CALL IT SCARY OR OF
A FAILURE OR POOR PERFORMANCE I
DID I WOULD JUST SAY THAT IT'S
IT'S PART OF THE LEARNING CURVE --
THAT BOTH DOJ AND LOCAL LAW FOR
TO HAS GO TO FOR EXAMPLE.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT NOT NOTIFYING US
WHEN THEY COLLECT A WEAPON THAT
WE'RE GONNA GO OUT THERE AND
HUNT FOR OURSELVES.
WE JUST AT THE COURTNEY ACOSTA
YOUR ABSOLUTE RIGHT THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC WHERE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT COLLECTS WEAPON BUT
NEVER INFORMS US AND WE'RE AFTER
IT'S SPINNING OUR WHEELS BUT
USING TAXPAYER MONEY. TO GET OUR
AGE IS READY TO COLLECT A WEAPON
THAT ALREADY GOT TURNED IT.
SAME TIME WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT HOW WE
COORDINATE WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WILL REQUIRE.
QUITE A BIT.
OF WORK COLLABORATION BECAUSE
THEY ARE LIMITED.
IN CERTAIN TERMS AS I SAID
JURISDICTION ONLY.
WE ARE OF LIMITED BY CAPACITY
AND WE HAVE TO TALK.
AND SO THERE IS ABSOLUTELY MORE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
BUT I WANT TO CONCLUDE BY SAYING
THIS.
AND I WOULD AYE AYE INVITE EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU. TO GO DO A
RIDE ALONG WITH THESE AGENTS. TO
SEE WHAT THEY DO.
IT IS SOMETIMES VERY DANGEROUS.
IT IS OFTEN TIMES VERY
FRUSTRATING.
BECAUSE THE THE THE THE THE THE
LEVELS.
THEY GO TO TO TRY TO FIND FOLKS.
WOULD FRUSTRATE.
AT BUT THEY HAVE NO CHOICE
BECAUSE THESE FOLKS ON THE LIST.
AND THE MORE WE CAN MAKE IT SO
THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A
SUCCESS.
THE BETTER OFF EVERYONE HE'S.
AND SO.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AS A
MEMBER WE DO NEED TO DO MUCH
MORE WHEN IT COMES TO
COORDINATION.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU.
I AM ABSOLUTELY PROUD OF THE
WORK.
THAT THE FIREARMS EIGHT
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THAT WE HAVE
HAVE DONE BECAUSE AS I SAID
PERHAPS THE BEST TESTAMENT IS
THE FACT THAT NO.
ONE HAS EVER GOT HURT IN THE
PROCESS OF COLLECTING.
THESE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
WEAPONS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
GEN ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
IN A QUESTIONS.
WE HAD A I'M SORRY MR TAKE NO GO
HEAD NO GO HEAD NO NO YOU'RE
FINE GO HIT.
I I APOLOGIZE I'M FINE THIS --
IN MY IN MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
LENSES QUESTIONS IF I END UP.
REPEATING HER QUESTIONS YOU CAN
JUST TELL ME YOU ANSWER THE MORE
IT WILL FINANCE WILL GET BETTER
I'M I'M SURE THEY'RE FABULOUS --
SO -- SO SO ONE ONE QUESTION'S
GOING BACK AND FORTH AND JUST
WHAT I WAS LOOKING AT IN TERMS
OF OUR STAFF ANALYSIS NOT TO GET.
I KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT APPS
BUT SENSE I MEAN I KNOW YOU TALK
ABOUT APPS NEXT.
I WANT TO JUST ASK A QUESTION OR
TWO ABOUT THAT IF THAT'S OKAY --
I I GUESS WHEN WE WERE LOOKING
AT SOME OF THE INITIAL DATA TO
LOOK LIKE THE PROJECTED BACKLOG
WAS GONNA COME DOWN EVENTUALLY
DOWN -- TO ABOUT LITTLE BIT
UNDER TWO THOUSAND BUT THEN I
GUESS THERE WAS MORE INFORMATION
SUBMITTED THAT SET THE BACKLOG
WOULD GO UP TO THIRTEEN THOUSAND
WHAT WAS THE AND AND I'M SORRY
FROM LOOKING AT TWO DIFFERENT.
CHARTS BUT JUST STONE YEAH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I CAN TRY TO
EXPLAIN THAT THE OUT OF A GRADE
WE WITH OUR REPORT THAT WE
SUBMITTED.
WE WE DECIDED.
TO I ADMIT AS IMAGE BEFORE WE WE
HAD A BORE DOWN. TO UNDERSTAND
THE APPS PROGRAM AND THE
TERMINOLOGY FOR EXAMPLE BACKLOT.
I I'M NOT SURE IF WE ALL WOULD.
THE FIND THE BACKLOG THE SAME
WAY IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN WE
SPOKE ABOUT BACKLOG I THINK
YOU'RE ABOUT THIRTEEN ALTHOUGH
THERE WERE ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
CASES LIKE MIKE I KEEP A CRACK
ME FORMA.
ABOUT TWENTY KEPT THOUSAND CASES
STILL OUTSTANDING.
ALL THOSE CASES FOR THE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES WHICH
PROBABLY WOULD NOT IDENTIFY TO
FOLKS BACK IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN IN THAT SAME
INTERVENING AMOUNT OF TIME TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF NEW PEOPLE HAVE
COME ON TO THE LIST THE APPS
LIST AS WHO HAVE WEAPONS THAT
HAVE TO BE RETRIEVED.
AT THE SAME TIME WE'VE BEEN
WORKING THE LIST TO REMOVE A LOT
OF FOLKS FROM THE WHAT WAS
CALLED THE BACKLOG AS WELL AS
THOSE THAT ARE COMING INTO THE
SYSTEM.
HERE'S THE THING.
SOMEONE HAS TO WAIT.
IF SOMEONE GETS IN LINE AND AND
WE'RE WE CAN'T GET TO THEM RIGHT
AWAY.
THEY BECOME PART OF THE BACK
WHAT THEY MAY HAVE ONLY BEEN
THERE FOR A MONTH.
BUT WE HAVE WORKED THE SOME
PEOPLE WHO HAD BEEN THERE FOR
YEARS AND SO WHAT WE TRY TO DO
WITH.
CLEAR UP WHAT THESE NUMBERS WERE
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN WHEN.
THE SO CALLED BACK WHAT WAS
IDENTIFIED.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT WAS ON THAT.
BACKLOG.
HAS EITHER BEEN [inaudible]
CLEARED.
IS WHAT WE NOW CALL PENDING IF
YOU LOOK AT A REPORT YOU'LL DO
YOUR WILL BE CLIP PENDING MEANS
WE TRY TO WORK THEM SEVERAL
TIMES.
BUT WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO SAY
FOR SURE.
THEY NO LONGER HAVE A WEAPON SO
WE CAN'T SAY THEY'RE CLEAR BUT
WE CAN'T SAY THEIR ACT BECAUSE
WE TRIED FIVE SIX TIMES.
AND THEN THERE'S THE ACTIVE
THOSE THAT WE'RE PURSUING.
ONGOING AND IF YOU ADD THOSE UP
THE ARE CLEARED.
THE PENDING AND THE ACTIVE THAT
WOULD OF SAID SHE GIVE YOU THE
TOTAL NUMBERS.
THAT IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WHAT A
BIG CLASSIFIED PRINCIPALLY IS
JUST BACK LOCK WHICH DOESN'T
REALLY GIVE YOU CLEAR SAID
BECAUSE AS I MENTIONED WE COULD
BE GOING AFTER SOMEONE.
WHO NO LONGER HAS A WEAPON?
BUT WE DON'T KNOW IT.
AND SO WE CAN'T CLEAR THE MATURE
WE KNOW FOR SURE.
AND SO THEY STAY ON OUR LISTING
WE CAN CLEAR THEM UNTIL IT'S
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR AND SO THAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE AND I HOPE YOU'LL
READ THE REPORT.
BECAUSE WE TOOK A LOT OF TIME
AND WE WE IDENTIFY SOME OF THE
WORDS THAT THE CUSTOMER NUMBER
LACKEY TRY TO POINT TO WE
IDENTIFIED THE WARTS IN THE
SYSTEM THE WAY HAVE BEEN
DESCRIBED BEFORE.
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS GET TO A
PLACE WHERE EVERYONE CAN AGREE
WITH THAT STANDARDIZED THE TERMS
LET'S LET'S NOT.
YOU KNOW LET'S MAKE SURE YOU'RE
CLEAR ON WHAT THE NUMBERS REALLY
SHOW BECAUSE THOUGH I THINK I
THINK ANY ONE OF US WANTS.
IS JEOPARDIZED THE SUCCESSFUL
WORK OF THIS PROGRAM WE WERE FOR
THE LONGEST TIME TAKING MONEY
OUT OF THE DRAWS ACCOUNT WHICH
IS THE DEALER -- RECORD OF SALE
ACCOUNT SO EVERY TIME SOMEONE
WANTS TO REGISTER.
AS A DEALER OR EVERY TIME WELL A
LAWFUL OWNER WANTS TO REGISTER.
WE USE THAT SYSTEM. TO TRACK
THEM.
BUT WE WERE TAKING GROWS BUNNY
WHICH IS TO HELP LAWFUL.
POSSESSORS OF WEAPONS OR SELLERS
OF WEAPONS TO GO AFTER THOSE WHO
HAD ILLEGALLY MAINTAIN
POSSESSION.
AND SO SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING
AND THIS IS WHAT THE GOVERNOR
SAID WHY SHOULD BE TAKING MONEY
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE USED TO
HELP WAFFLE FOLKS STATE.
CURRENT STAY CURRENT AND AND
MAKE SURE THEY'RE THEY'RE BY
BYLAW AND USE IT TO GO AFTER THE
THE GOT BAD GUYS.
WHICH YOU GET MONEY SEPARATELY
SO WE DON'T UNDERMINE THE
ABILITY OF THE GOOD GUYS TO DO
IT THE RIGHT WAY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE GOVERNOR DID
IN THIS IN THIS CASE HE'S GIVEN
US BUDDY OUT A GENERAL FUND. TO
FINALLY CATCH UP SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO SCRAPE MONEY
OUT OF THE DRAWS FUND AND AWAY
FROM THE WAFFLE.
REGISTRATION ACTIVITIES WE HAVE
SO WE CAN DO THE STUFF GOING
AFTER THE BAD GUYS.
IN AND SO THEN DE DO YOU HAVE
THE SO SUGGEST TO RE.
JUST UNDERSTOOD REPEAL CAN WHAT
YOU JUST SAID.
SO CLEARLY AS YOU FROM YOU
EITHER -- GOT THE GUNS OR YOU
FOUND THAT THE PERSON.
MAYBE WHY YEAH DID THE DIDN'T
HAVE WEAPONS OR WHATEVER THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE CLEAR RIGHT OR I
GUESS SOME PEOPLE NO WEAPON IN
HAND THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED OR
IF THEY'RE NO LONGER
PROHIBITIONS APART THOUGH THOSE
ARE ALL IN THE CLEAR CLEAR.
RIGHT SHE GOT PENDING WHICH IS
PEOPLE THAT YOUR YOU YOU COULD
BE WORKING MAYBE THEY DON'T HAVE
GUNS BE SINCE YOU HAVEN'T TALKED
TO THEM YOU DON'T REALLY KNOW IF.
WE HAVE ANY AND WE ACTUALLY ARE
NO LONGER WORKING AND BUT WE
HAVE TO KEEP IN A BAY IT'S LIKE
A WHOLE CASE.
WE TRY TO TRY TO TRY BUT WE
COULD ONLY SPINNER WITH SO MANY
TIMES SAID SENATOR THERE'S
ACTIVE ACT BECAUSE THAT YOU'RE
ACTIVELY LOOKER WHAT'S.
SAUCE I GUESS THE BETTER NUMBER
FOR US WOULD BE WHAT IS.
ACTIVE.
WHAT'S ACTIVE SO -- A CASE WHERE
WE ARE OUR ARE IN HIS OFFICE I
DO HAVE THE NUMBER FOR WHAT.
AND ACTUALLY LET ME ASK MARTY
HER AND WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE FIREARMS BUREAU TO TAKE A
SEAT WITH ME PIECE HERE.
HE'S HE'S WALKING UP YEAH
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO GIVE YOU
RUN NUMBER -- AND HE TO HAVE
THEM.
AND AGAIN THIS IS GONNA LOOK
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT ANY REPORT
YOU SAW TWENTY THIRTEEN TO
TWENTY FOURTEEN BECAUSE WE'VE
ACTUALLY TRY TO BREAK IT DOWN
THE HIGHLIGHT SO GIVE A QUICK
EXAMPLE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE LEFT
THE STATE.
WE DON'T HAVE JURISDICTION TO GO
AFTER FOLKS IN ANOTHER STATE.
AND SO THEY HAVE A WEAPON SO IN
OUR APPS SYSTEM [inaudible]
THEY EXIST.
BUT I COULD NEVER CLEAR THEM.
UNTIL THEY COME BACK INTO THE
STATE'S RIGHT GO AFTER SO YOU'LL
SAY WELL HOW WHY HAVEN'T YOU
COULD BACK OUT OF THESE VERY --
CASES AND IN SOME CASES BECAUSE
I CAN'T GO AFTER THEM.
BUT IN THE TWENTY THIRTY TWENTY
FOURTEEN REPORT YOU COULD NEVER
IDENTIFIED LET ME OF MARTY GO
AHEAD GIVE YOU THE NUMBERS YES I
JUST BE GOOD TO KNOW BECAUSE OF
WHAT'S.
ACTED WHAT'S PENDING WITH
CLEARED.
A YES SIR SO IT AS OF THE END OF
DECEMBER -- WHICH IS INDICATED
IN OUR REPORT WE WE'RE DOWN TO
NINETY FIVE DECEMBER. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN YES.
WE'RE DOWN TO NINE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND FOUR ACTIVE CASES --
BUT IN THAT PROCESS WE WE'VE
COMPLETELY -- ELIMINATED THE
ORIGINAL BACKLOG FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN AND AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAD EXPLAINED
WE TRY TO DO A BETTER JOB.
OF EXPLAINING ALL THESE NUMBERS
IN THIS REPORT BECAUSE WE COULD
SEE IT WAS GETTING CONFUSING
OVER THE YEARS WE KEPT TALKING
ABOUT WORKLOAD SHORE BACKLOG.
THE NUMBER WAS GETTING CONFUSED
WITH WHAT IS THE CURRENT NUMBER
OF ACTIVE CASES VERSES.
HOW WELL WE'VE ATTACKED THE
ORIGINAL BACK LOG OF ACTIVE
CASES FROM TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
SUIT SO WHAT WAS CLEARED IN?
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO IN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE TERM BACKLOG WE HAD
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWO AT TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TWENTY
ONE ACTIVE CASES IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AT THE END
OF TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WE
HAD FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT CASES ABOUT ORIGINAL STILL
REMAINING.
IN KIND OF SPARSE AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA YES I I WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE NOT CONFUSING THE
GERMANS.
MARTY THAT REFERRING TO WHAT
USED TO BE CALLED THE BACKLOG
RIGHT A CASES THAT EXISTED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN WHICH DOESN'T.
REFLECT THE NUMBER OF CASES WE
HAVE TODAY SO STARTED TO BE
FAVOR OF LET'S TALK ABOUT.
FORGET ABOUT THE TWENTY THIRTY
CHARACTERS RATING BECAUSE
EVERYONE WAS IN THE BACKLOG
UNLESS WE WERE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GONNA SO SO SO SO SO SO -- THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL JUST TALKED
ABOUT THREE THREE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES RIGHT ACTIVE.
CLEARED HANDY AND THAT
DEFINITIONS BEING USED BY THE
DEPARTMENT.
WOULD ASK FOR ANY IS THAT IS
THAT CORRECT YES OKAY.
SO SO.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN HOW MANY
FOLKS WERE CLEARED.
AND HOW MANY FOLKS ARE.
PENDING AN IMAGE CHáVEZ AT THE
END OF DECEMBER IF I COULD MAKE
SURE SO MARTY ANSWERS IT THE WAY
I HOPE YOU'RE NOT THINK YOU'RE
TRYING TO GET.
TO NOT CLEARED THAT WERE IN THE
TWENTY THIRTEEN BLACK Là CALL
JUST CLEARED YEAH UNDER A NEW
DEFINITION IF SOMEBODY IN THE
COULD HAVE BEEN YOU JUST CLICK
THAT YOU'RE DEBTS I THOUGHT
SOUNDS LIKE THAT SOME OF WHAT
YOU DID LAST YEAR WHICH YOU
CLEAN UP YOUR DATABASE RIGHT.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE PASSED AWAY
THEY'RE OFF THE DATA THAT'S
RIGHT FOR WHATEVER REASON THEY
WERE.
BUT YOU DO WAY THROUGH AND TOOK
A TOOK -- YOU KNOW SCRUB SCRUB
YOUR INFORMATION AND TOOK SOME
PEOPLE OFF.
CORRECT SO INTO THAT BY THE END
OF TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WE
HAD CLEARED TEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE SUBJECTS
FROM.
THE APPS DATABASE IN AND THAT IS
JUST IN THE CALENDAR YEAR YOU'RE
TALKING THAT IS JUST IN THAT
CALENDAR YEAR OKAY PERFECT.
GERMAN ASK HOW MANY WE GOT.
SO DIDN'T WILL ACT ACTIVE WAS
NINE THOUSAND FOUR OF FOUR WELL
IT AB I THINK WITH THE WHOLE.
YOUR SIM THAT SAME YEAR OKAY WE
HAD RECEIVED ELEVEN THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE NEW
OUT LEVY THOUSAND HOW MANY SIR
LEVIN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE IN THE CHAMBER THE
POINT OF THAT SHOW YOU THAT WE
COULD OVER.
TEN THOUSAND BUT WE GOT NEW NOT
EXISTED BEFORE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN THOUSAND SURE SO SOME
WOULD SAY WELL YOU'RE FALLING
BEHIND AND IN A WAY YOU THAT'S
RIGHT BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
ENTERING THE SYSTEM.
AND WE STILL HAD A CLEAR THE
FOLKS THAT EXISTED FROM WAY BACK
WHEN.
THE AND THAT'S THE POINT THAT
NEVER CAME THROUGH AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR MEMBERS TO
UNDERSTAND.
WELL WITHIN THAT THAT THAT'S WHY
I THINK IT'D BE A BE HELPFUL. TO
ON AGAIN YOU YOU HAVE  BACKWARD
LOOKING DATA BUT SAID YOU SORT
OF STARTED LOOKING AT DATE A
LITTLE BIT TO FLARE OUR STATE
MADE THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO BREAK OUT MORE.
RIGHT SAYS THAT THIS IS MUCH A
LOT CLEARER SO THEN PENDING
WHAT'S IN YOUR PENDING CATEGORY
BECAUSE OF VESSELS INTENDING AS
OF THE END OF THE YEAR WAS ABOUT.
THIRTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
CASES WERE IN THOSE CASES.
YOU'RE YOU'RE JUST PUTTING IN
LIKE A PARKING LOT BUT YOU'RE
NOT YOU'RE NOT WORKING.
CORRECT WE'VE ALREADY WORKED
THOSE CASES YES -- SO THERE THE
EITHER -- FALL INTO A CATEGORY
OF UNABLE TO CLEAR.
TYPICALLY THOSE ARE FOLKS WERE
WE'VE MAY BE SEIZED ALREADY A
COUPLE OTHER FIREARMS BUT WE
WERE UNABLE TO LOCATE THE OTHER
ONES ASSOCIATED WITH THEM AND
TELL WEAKENED.
RECOVER THOSE WEAPONS WE CAN'T
CLEAR THEM FROM THE SYSTEM.
THE OTHER CATEGORIES OUT OF
STATE SO SINCE THEY BECAME
PROHIBITED THEY'VE NOW MOVED OUT
OF STATE -- WE STILL HAVE TO
KEEP TRACK OF THEM IN CASE THEY
COME BACK INTO THE STATE BUT
THERE'S REALLY NOTHING ELSE FOR
US TO DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA ON
THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT LIST
DEPENDING COULD BE. FOUR MONTHS
OLD.
OR FOUR YEARS OLD CORRECT
BECAUSE DOT THE WE CAN'T CLEAR
THEM WE CAN'T WE CAN'T DISPOSE
OF THEM.
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT SOME
OF THE CONFUSION COMES IN.
BECAUSE FOLKS AREN'T TRACK IT
FOLKS LOOKING AT THIS AS A
STATIC NUMBER IT'S NOT STATIC
BECAUSE EVERY DAY SOMEONE WHO
COMES INTO THE SYSTEM AND EVERY
DAY WE CLEAR SOMEONE.
AT EVERY DAY WE MOVE SOMEONE
INTO THE PENDING LIST.
IN AN OF OF THE IN ON IF YOU
HAVE THIS NUMBER BUT JUST.
OF OF THE ONES THAT WERE CLEAR
THE TEN THOUSAND SIX EIGHTY ONE
HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE CLEAR
BECAUSE YOU ACTUALLY.
SEIZE THEIR WEAPONS REQUEST.
SO WE WE HAVE THAT BROKEN UP
INTO THREE CATEGORIES FOR TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN TWO
NUMBERS.
SO FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO WERE DISARMED THIS
ORDER. TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ONE MORE INDIVIDUALS THAT PASSED
AWAY SOUTHERN STATE THEY COME
OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
AND SIX THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY EIGHT HAD EXPIRED
PROHIBITIONS SO THEY COME OUT OF
THE SYSTEM -- ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
IN THE BACK AND FORTH QUESTION
ANSWERS THE IS.
THIS SIX THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT ARE COMING OUT
WITHOUT ANY WORK BEING DONE AND
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT TRUE
THOSE THOSE ARE CASES LIKE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SO THEY COULD
HAVE BEEN AND ARE PENDING SYSTEM
FOR FOUR YEARS WE'VE ALREADY
WORKED THOSE CASES AND NOW THEY
WERE PARKED.
IN ONE OF THOSE PENDING AREAS
AND THE NATURALLY -- A
PROHIBITION EXPIRES OR SOMETHING
HAPPENS THEY THEY THEY COME OUT
THEN.
IN IN THE FOR EXPIRED PROVISIONS
CAN YOU GIVE US AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT MIGHT BE LIKE EXPIRE
PROVISION EXPIRE PROHIBITION
COULD BE SOMEBODY THAT IS -- HAS
A RESTRAINING ORDER ON THEM
LET'S SAY A THIRTY DAY SIX
MONTHS A YEARS -- RESTRAINING
ORDER THAT -- IT ENDS IT COULD
BE SOMEBODY THAT HAD -- MAYBE A
FIVE YEAR PROHIBITION FOR
CERTAIN VIOLATION MENTAL HEALTH
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THE NOW THE
FIVE YEARS HAS EXPIRED THEY NOW
COME OUT.
THANK YOU -- IN SO WITH -- YOU
KNOW TO JUST TO JUST TO GET BACK
ON MY MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS REGARDING LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THINK THERE'S WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS IN YOUR THOUGHTS AROUND
THAT -- IT IS IT'S A TIME I
THINK WHERE THERE IS SOME
INTEREST ESPECIALLY SOME SOME
LOCAL LEADERSHIP LOCAL LAW FOR
SEPTEMBER DOES WANT.
TO WANT TO PARTNER WITH YOU SO
WE WOULD LOVE TO FIGURE OUT --
WAYS TO EXPLORE SPECIALLY YOU
KNOW WHICH YOU KNOW YOU TO LOVE
TO GET ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AND ALL THE DIFFERENT CITIES TO
BE ON FOR THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
SO IT'S JUST TRYING TO FIND
WHICH AGENCIES WHICH DEPARTMENTS
REALLY WANT TO TAKE THE LEAD IN
THIS SEEMS LIKE THERE'S SOME
INTEREST IN DIFFERENT APARTMENTS
AROUND THE STATE'S REALLY HOPE
YOU WOULD.
YOU AND YOUR TEAM WOULD JUST.
EXPLORE THOSE AND I THINK WE CAN
WE CAN HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT CREATIVE
WAYS ON HOW TO HOW TO SUPPORT
THAT I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
INTEREST.
IN MAKING SURE YOU KNOW CLEARLY
THESE THESE FOLKS HAVE BEEN
<c.red>DENTIFIED AS PEOPLE WHO REALLY</c>
SHOULDN'T HAVE FIREARMS FOR THE
REASON.
THAT WE REALLY -- WORK TOGETHER
STATE AND LOCAL TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU KNOW IF THEY'RE NOT
DISARMED AND THERE'S BUSINESS
SOME REASON.
THEY'RE NOT DISARMED I MEAN I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT MISTER
CHAIRMAN ON THAT ON THAT POINT --
I HOPE YOU WHAT YOU'LL KEEP IN
MIND.
IS THAT [inaudible]
LOCAL AGENCIES.
CANNOT DO THIS THEMSELVES IF
THEY TRY IF THEY SAY YOU HELP US
BY GIVING US RESOURCE TO DO THIS
THEY CAN'T BECAUSE THE MOMENT --
ONE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS LEAVES
YOUR JURISDICTION THEY HAVE TO
STOP AND SO.
IT HAD IF FORCES ALL OF US TO
COORDINATE AND AGAIN TEN YEARS
AGO THERE WERE ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO WERE --
OWNING FIREARMS IN CALIFORNIA.
TODAY JUST TEN YEARS LATER
THAT'S TWO AND A HALF MILLION.
AND SO THE NUMBERS ARE
INCREASING AND THAT MEANS MUCH
MORE WORK FOR US AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S SO CRITICAL THAT WE DO
COORDINATE.
AND COLLABORATE WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- THERE'S A
QUESTION TO DETER THERE'S A
REASON WHY YOUR YOUR THE HOLDER
OF THE DATABASE.
AND YOUR AGENCIES THAT ONE
CHARGED WITH MANAGING NOW.
HAVING SAID THAT -- YOU KNOW YOU
YOU CAN'T DO IT ALONE AND THEY
CAN TO THIS IS NO QUESTION THE
SOLUTION IS AND EVERYBODY.
WORKING TOGETHER BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW CLEARLY CLEARLY FROM A A
RESOURCE POINT OF VIEW IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT ADEQUATELY RESOURCE TO
DO THAT THE CAN TO QUESTIONS IS --
WHAT MAKES SENSE TO TO GO WITH
YOUR AGENCY TO SOME PEACE MAKES
SENSE TO GO WITH THE LOCALS AND
IT'S IT'S BUT IT'S REALLY A
PARTNERSHIP?
IT HAS TO BE WHERE WERE YOUR
AGENCY WORKS WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES ARE HANDED
HIM I THINK THERE'S NO OTHER WAY
TO BE SUCCESSFUL FRANKLIN.
SO.
THANK YOU -- I WAS GOING TO
SIMPLY MISS MISS MELENDEZ HAD TO
LEAVE AND SO SHE ASKED ME -- TO
ASK A QUESTION I GUESS -- YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU HAVE
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF THE
RETRIEVAL AT THE TIME OF OF THE
DECISION THAT'S MADE THAT THEY
SHOULD NOT HAVE.
FIRE ARMS SHE WAS SAYING WHAT DO
YOU DO FOR THE FIFTY ONE FIFTIES
WHO DON'T HAVE.
OF COURT DATES AND THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS.
IN MY PARTY MIGHT HAVE A BETTER
ANSWER THAN I DO ON THAT -- I'M
NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION NOW SHE'S THE SOME OF
THESE FOLKS ARE WHAT THEY THE
BURDEN OF FIFTY ONE FIFTY BILL
KIND OF MENTAL.
ISSUES THAT ARE THERE AND THEY
DON'T HAVE -- SHE SAID THEY'RE
NOT BASICALLY ON AND IN JAIL OR
UNDER SUPERVISION OR THEY'RE NOT
IN COURT.
SO WHO SHE SAID WHAT DO YOU DO
ABOUT THEM AND I I ASSUME --
THIS CONSIDERATION FOR THAT SO
WE WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
MEASURE WE WE WE CAN ONLY PURSUE
FOLKS WHO UNDER THE LAW.
FIT THE CRITERIA AS PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LOST THE RIGHT TO POSSESS
WEAPONS.
AND SO WHETHER SOMEONE -- COMES
OUT OF THE SYSTEM BECAUSE THEIR
TIME FOR EXAMPLE UNDER TO
DOMESTIC RESTRAINING ORDER ENDS
OR WHETHER THERE HAS BEEN SOME
KIND OF A JUDICATA -- THAT
THERE'S A MENTAL -- DISABILITY
THAT MAKES A PERSON DANGER TO
HIMSELF OR OTHERS WE CAN'T
PURSUE THOSE FOLKS WE HAVE TO
THEY HAVE TO FIT WITHIN THE
DEFINITIONS OF THE SUBJECTS.
THAT ARE NO LONGER ALLOWED TO
POSSESS WEAPONS.
YOU MENTION ANY IN YOUR COMMENTS.
SOMETHING ABOUT -- I THINK SENT
AND MY COLLEAGUE HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT IT SOMETHING ABOUT THE
RAPE KITS YES AND I I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE OF THEWAS THE LAST
WEEK WE HAD A REPORT CONCERNING
THE BRAKE KITS.
AND THE FACT THAT MANY OF THEM
THAT WE'VE ORDERED MOST OF THEM
TO BE TESTED.
BUT THEY'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING
WITH SOME.
OF ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH THAT AND AND WHAT
RESOLUTION.
OUGHT TO OCCUR WITH REGARDS TO
THAT WE WERE SOMEWHAT SHOCKED AT
THE NOTED THAT THE NUMBER THAT
IS OUT THE IN THE AFTER WE PUT
RESOURCES INTO.
OF TELLING FOLKS THAT THEY HAVE
TO BE CITIZENS THESE KIDS NEED
TO BE TESTED AND FOLKS GET UP IN
TESTAMENT IN THE DO NOTHING WITH
THE THE THE THE THE HITS THAT
COMEY AND THAT COULD PROBABLY
PREVENT.
OF CRIMES FROM OCCURRING OR AT
LEAST EVEN OF HELP FOLKS WHO
BEEN UNFAIRLY -- CONVICTED OF
CRIMES THAT THEY DID NOT COMMIT
SO.
OUT WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH ALL
OF THAT THAT WAS VERY
FRUSTRATING FOR US TO HEAR THAT
AT THE SAME TIME -- AT LEAST I
WAS ENCOURAGED BY THE IS IS THAT
IS THE ISSUE IS THE IS THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
OF SITUATION OF THE DIDN'T HAVE
A BACKLOG OF WITH REGARDS TO
BRAKE KITS AND HAS USED A MALL
FOR WHATEVER PROSECUTION AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON IT THEY'RE GOING
TO USE -- INDICATED THAT IT'S
REALLY A MATTER OF WILL THAT
FOLKS HAVE TO MAKE IT A PRIORITY
TO GET THIS DONE AND I KNOW
THEY'VE BEEN SEVERAL DISCUSSIONS
AND BILLS FROM WOMEN.
IN THE ASSEMBLY OF GETTING THIS
DONE AND SO WOULD NOW AT A POINT
WHERE.
WE STILL FIND OURSELVES A
WITHOUT THE RESULTS THAT WE WANT
FROM THESE RAPE KITS.
VENTURE SO LIKE THE SITUATION
WITH THE FIREARMS HELD BY PEOPLE
WHO ARE PROHIBITED.
UP.
THERE ISN'T A SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO DO
ANYTHING IN PARTICULAR WITH US
ON THE ON FIREARMS.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO THE RAPE
KITS THEY GO THROUGH THEM AS
THEY DEEM -- APPROPRIATE AND SO
THERE HAS GROWN UP A BACKLOG OF
SOME OF THESE KIDS HAS GROWN.
MANY OF THOSE AGENCIES.
ASK OUR FRIENDS X. -- US BUREAU
FORENSIC SERVICES TO DO THE
ANALYSIS OF SOME OF THOSE
EVIDENCE KITS AND WE DO AND SO
WHEN I MENTIONED THAT WE HAD WE
ARE OVER THE COURSE OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PERFORMED -- ANALYSIS
OF THOSE KIDS WE DID ABOUT
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED SO THE
REQUEST THAT WE GOT WE PROCESSED
ALL OF THOSE.
THERE ARE SOME AGENCIES THAT ARE
STILL HOLDING SOME OF THESE KIDS.
IN SOME CASES FOR A LONGER TIME
THAN SOME PEOPLE THINK
REASONABLE AND IT'S UP TO THOSE
AGENCIES TO TRY TO GET THEM
ANALYZED.
AND SO THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
TRIED TO PROVIDE THE IMPETUS FOR
FOR THAT TO BE DONE SOONER AND
IN SOME CASES RESOURCES ARE
GONNA HELP SOME OF THESE LOCAL
AGENCIES DO SO AS WELL.
AND WE WE MAY RUN INTO A
SITUATION WHERE WE CAN'T KEEP UP
AS WELL IF TOO MANY THESE
AGENCIES START COMING TO US.
BECAUSE AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
FORENSIC SERVICES HAS ALREADY
BEEN DEPLETED AND IT'S FUNDING
AND SO OUR ABILITY TO TAKE ON
MORE WILL BE STRAPPED UNLESS WE
CONTINUE.
TO GET THE RESOURCES WE NEED.
OKAY.
WELL I GUESS WE'LL HAVE TO AT IN
IN LISTENING -- LAST WEEK TO THE
TO IT -- I GUESS AT SOME POINT
THIS BODY WILL HAVE.
TO DO SOMETHING IN TERMS OF THAT
ONLY BUDGET BUT BUDGET LANGUAGE.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO DO A
TO FOLLOW DO THE FOLLOW THROUGH.
YOU KNOW AS I POINTED OUT
REMINDS ME WHEN YOU TELL YOU
KßT.
TO SWEEP BECAUSE THEY DROP
SOMETHING A SUITE THAT ONE SPOT
MANDATE THAT DONE INVEST A HOUSE
LOOK LIKE A DISASTER.
AND AND AND IT SEEMS LIKE THE
SAME WE TOLD ME OF TEST THE TEST.
YOU KNOW LOGIC IS THAT DO BEEN
TAKE IT INTO TO ITS LOGICAL
CONCLUSION AND OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
NOT HAPPENING SO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE.
TO FIGURE OUT SOMETHING WITH
REGARDS TO FUNDING BUT ALSO
BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE THAT
REQUIRES THEM TO TAKE IT TO ITS
FULL IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE PURPOSE OF OF DOING THE
TEST IS TO HOPEFULLY TO PROVE
FIGURE OUT WHO'S COMMITTING THE
CRIMES AND AND PICK THESE FOLKS
UP AS WELL AS TO EXONERATE FOLKS
DIDN'T COMMIT THE CRIME I MEAN.
THAT'S THE LOGIC BEHIND IT AND
AND YET ARE WE GETTING IS IS THE
TEST THEY'RE BEING TESTED
BECAUSE WE TOLD MODESTO.
AND THEY'RE NOT FOLLOWING
THROUGH ON THE HITS OR ANYTHING
ELSE FROM THE REPORT THAT WE GOT.
IN LAST WEEK AND SO THAT'S
REALLY KIND OF DISHEARTENING
AFTER SO MANY YEARS OF OF I
REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT THAT WHICH HAS BEEN
SEVERAL WEEKS YEARS AGO NOW.
AND WE STILL A POOR ALMOST AT
THE SAME SPOT WITH REGARDS TO
PEOPLE FOLLOWING THROUGH AS WE
THOUGHT THEY WOULD LOGICALLY
FOLLOW THROUGH ONCE THEY GOT
YOUR OFFICE AND OTHERS TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
INFORMATION.
BUT IT'S NOT IT DOESN'T SOME OUT
OF THE CORD NATION NOT TRICKLING
DOWN AND AND ACCOMPLISHING THE
GOALS THAT WE THOUGHT WOULD
ACCOMPLISH.
BY GETTING THE TEST THAT -- BUT
THAT WE SAW WHAT CAN HAPPEN IS
WITH THE ONE BE A WHO ACTUALLY
MADE IT A PRIORITY TO COMMITMENT.
TO GET THE TEST HOPE THINGS DONE
AND TO FOLLOW THROUGH WITH IT
AND AND TO HAVE NO BACKLOG IN IN
THE BAY AREA WITH WITH REGARDS --
TO THE RAPE KITS AND THE FOLLOW
THROUGH AND HITS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT WE THOUGHT WOULD
PEOPLE WOULD DO.
YOU KNOW BUT SHE SAID SHE HAD A
COMMITMENT TO GET IT DONE.
SO WHAT WILL FIT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS YES MISTER JONES
SAWYER.
IT IS OCT.
I APOLOGIZE FOR FOR BEING SO
LATE AND IF THIS.
QUESTION IS ALREADY BEEN BEEN
ASSN ANSWER OUT OF A WASH THE
FILLMORE SMOKES PLAYED TO ME
LATER -- IT'S NOT JUST FIRST
MAKE MAKE A COMMENT ON THE ARM
TO PROHIBIT PERSON SYSTEM --
GOOD TO SEE YOU MISTER DURING
GENERAL OF I'VE HAD.
IN PUBLIC SAFETY POLICY -- I'VE
HAD MEMBERS WANTING TO CREATE
THEIR OWN [inaudible]
INDIVIDUAL [inaudible]
DEPARTMENT -- APPS SYSTEM OR
WHATEVER.
AND I'VE OF KIND OF HELD IT BACK
BECAUSE OF FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE.
AND ALSO FROM A MANAGEMENT
PERSPECTIVE OF ALWAYS FELT THAT --
I THINK I TELL YOU THAT THAT I I
PREFER ONE PERSON TO BLAME ONE
PERSON TO GET SUCCESS.
OF WHEN YOU SPREAD THINGS OVER.
DIFFERENT SHERIFFS ARE DIFFERENT
[inaudible]
AGENCIES ARM WHEN -- SOMEONE
ASKED WHY DIDN'T WORK PEOPLE
STOP POINTING FINGERS AND YOU
GOT.
YOU KNOW FOR FIVE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES WORKING ON THIS AND
FOUR OUT OF FIVE OUR SUCCESSFUL --
YOU'VE GOT TO BLAME FOR PEOPLE
FIVE PEOPLE WHAT THE ART YOU GO
BACK TO LEGISLATION SO WHY DO
YOU DO THAT THE FIRST PLACE.
AND SO ON I THINK WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS -- I WAS HERE.
IN TWENTY TWELVE TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
AND MIGHT MIGHT. ONE I'M LETTING
YOU KNOW THAT -- IS PROBABLY
SOME MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY NOT
VERY HAPPY WITH ME BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT DOING.
THIS BECAUSE I FIRMLY BUT DO
BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD BE REST
IN.
ONE DEPARTMENT ONE ONE AREA I
THINK YOU WERE WILD WHEN I CAME
IN YOU CAN I ANSWERED SOME OF
THE REASONS WHY WE NEED TO GET
THAT OUT TO OTHER MEMBERS.
A WIDE IS IS MORE IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IT FOCUS UNDER ONE PERSON'S
LEADERSHIP.
OTHERWISE -- IT STILL MAY NOT
GET DONE -- THAT'S ONE THING AND
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU DO ACTUALLY
WORK WITH LOCAL MISS BELLY TO
MAKE SURE IT GETS DONE -- THAT
AND IN MY ONLY QUESTION IS --
WHAT'S WHAT IS WHAT WILL BE THE
DIFFERENCE.
BETWEEN WHAT THE EFFORT THAT WAS
DONE BACK IN 200-012-1314.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN YOU CAME ON WHAT.
SEVENTEEN WHAT'S WHAT IS GOING
TO BE DIFFERENT THAN THE MONEY
WE PUT IN LAST TIME THAT THE
ACTIVITY WE PUT AWAY WHAT IS.
WHAT IS THAT DELTA DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO?
AND WHAT WAS ATTEMPTED BEFORE TO
GET US TO WHERE WE WANT TO GO.
SOME REMEMBER AS A GREAT
QUESTION AND I WOULD TELL YOU
THAT.
MY HOPE IS THAT WHAT WE CAN
PRODUCE FOR MOVING FORWARD IF WE
GET THIS UP BUDGET REQUEST IT
HELPS TO SORT OF BUT THE DECK IN
ORDER.
IS EFFICIENCY THAT WE WILL
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO COORDINATE
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU
MAKE YOU WE MIGHT NEED YOUR HELP.
TO THE TOP.
GIVE A PUSH TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT EIGHTY TO WANT TO DO
THIS THEY'RE GONNA COME TO YOU
AND RIGHTFULLY SO MANY CASES SAY.
YOU WANT US TO GET INVOLVED IT'S
GONNA TAKE SOME RESOURCES
BECAUSE EVERY TIME WE GO
RETRIEVE A WEAPON.
WE'RE NOT HAVING SOMEBODY PATROL
STREET.
AND SO IT'S A LEGITIMATE CONCERN
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS
FIGURE OUT THE MOST EFFICIENT
WAY TO COORDINATE SO IT.
LOOKS LIKE MY ARM.
TECH APPREHEND FOLKS.
IS MUCH LONGER AND BIGGER AND
WHAT IT IS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
WITH THE FEW TEAMS I HAVE TO DO
THIS.
FOLKS KNOW IT'S GONNA BE TOUGH
FOR ME TO FIND.
BUT IF I KNOW THERE'S A NETWORK
OUT THERE THAT I'M WORKING WITH
THAT WE'RE COORDINATING
OFFICIALLY.
THAT'S WHAT REALLY WORKS FIRST
IS AS YOU SAID IF ONE AGENCY
SAID LET ME TAKE IT ALL ON MY
OWN.
AND THEN THE MOMENT THAT
PERSON'S STEPS OVER THE BOUNDARY
THAT PERSON'S JURISDICTION YOU
KNOW LA COUNTY SHERIFF.
CAN'T GOING TO ORANGE COUNTY AS
I SAID BEFORE AND THEY ALL THEY
KNOW IS THAT THE BAD GUYS KNOW
THE AGE THAT THE STEP OVER THE
COUNTY LINE.
AND THE CASHIER CAN'T TOUCH HIM
ANYMORE.
BE IT BECOMES INEFFICIENT AND SO
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS COORDINATE
SO THAT.
LA COUNTY SAYS I'M ABOUT THE
PURSUE SOMEBODY LOOKS LIKE IT'S
ABOUT THE GOING TO ORANGE COUNTY
AS TO HOW WE GOT A WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH ORANGE COUNTY
ORANGE COUNTY.
TAKES OVER FROM THERE AND THEN
WE DON'T HAVE TO MY TEAM DOES IT
HAVE TO ALWAYS BE ON THE GROUND.
BUT WITHOUT A DOUBT THERE'S GOT
TO BE -- SOMEONE AT THE POINT OF
THE SPEAR AND THAT'S WHERE
SPECIAL AGENTS HAVE BEEN AT THE
POINT OF THE SPEAR AND WITH YOUR
HELP WHAT WILL END UP DOING I
HOPE IS COORDINATING.
AND WITH YOUR HELP ALTHOUGH THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING YOU CAN
DIRECTLY DO.
BUT MAYBE THE MORAL SUASION YOU
CAN PROVIDE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STATE RECOGNIZES THAT I
CAN'T DO SOMETHING.
WHEN I GATICA A MEDIC
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE TRYING
TO GET THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO THAT WORK?
AND IF I CAN'T BE MY AGENT
SOMETHING NEAR WHAT THEY DESERVE
GIVEN THAT THE HEIGHT OF DANGER
THAT THEY'RE IN -- I'M NOT GONNA
GET A AND SO WE WE JUST NEED TO
MAKE IT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT.
WE WANT TO WE WANT TO GET THE
BEST.
HARD TO GET THE BEST IF I PAY
THE WORST.
WELL IS WITH THE WITH THE
TESTING A RAPE KIT -- WE COULD
PROVIDE.
ALL THE MONIES THAT WE NEED ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
BUT IF THEY'RE NOT COOPERATING
IF YOU'RE NOT DOING YOU KNOW
I'VE THE REASON I'M LATE.
IS BECAUSE OF A A BILL I'M
WORKING ON IN THE MORNING AT
EIGHT THIRTY WERE BY -- I THINK
THIS COMMITTEE GAVE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION TO HELP RESOLVE JUMPING
AND HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT DO IT
ON THEIR OWN.
WHICH THEY DIDN'T TOUCH.
IN SOME ALSO WORRIED ABOUT
GIVING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THEN HAVE THEM NOT USE.
YOU DO WE GIVE YOU ALL THE
RESOURCES YOU NEED.
BUT THEN THEY DON'T CONNECT WITH
YOU SO IT'S IT'S IT'S MORE THAN
JUST.
YOU IT'S IS ALSO THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT MAKING THIS A
PRIORITY.
AREN'T MAKING IS SOMETHING THAT.
UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP THEY WILL
MOVE FORWARD WITH.
AND SO -- WE WE WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THAT TOO BECAUSE THAT'S
OTHERWISE WE HAVE.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT IS
EITHER UNSPENT.
OR MISUSED.
AND WE STILL ARE AT THE SAME
PLACE THAT WE ARE HERE RIGHT NOW
AND SO -- THERE MAY BE SOME
LEGISLATION THAT WE NEED OTHER
THAN GIVING MONEY WE MAY NEED
SOME LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY.
SAID AND I WANT YOU TO THINK
ABOUT THAT. TO HELP ENSURE THAT
THIS GETS DONE.
SOMETIMES SOME.
LIKE DOCTOR WEBER SAYS YOU EVEN
LET [inaudible]
YOUR KIDS.
MEMBERS WITH THE WHOLE HOUSE.
YOU CAN SAY LET'S GET THIS DONE
AND THEN YOU LOOK AROUND IT'S
NOT QUITE.
DONE INSULT THIS IS SO THIS IS
OF GREAT IMPORTANCE OF BOTH
SIDES OF THE HOUSE.
THAT -- I THINK WE CAN WE NEED
TO WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
THIS GETS DONE.
THANK AGREE THANK YOU MISTER
LACKEY HAVE ONE LAST QUESTION.
YEAH I JUST LIKE TO CLARIFY
THOUGH THE ONE POINT THAT I MADE
ABOUT -- IF YOU GO TO THE
WEBSITE WE HAVE SOME PRETTY
OUTDATED CIRCUMSTANCES HERE
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS TRY TO DO
IS TO IS TO COMPLY.
M. WHEN GUN OWNERS HAVE THEIR
REQUIRED TO DISPLAY THIS VERY
STATEMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S STRICT GUN LAWS
PERTAINING TO FIRE ARMS A NEW
WAVE.
YOU MAY BE FINED OR IMPRISONED
IF YOU FAIL TO COMPLY WITH THEM.
VISIT THE WEBSITE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND AS I INDICATED.
THIS IS WHAT THEY'LL GET. TWENTY
SIXTEEN YOUR NAME'S NOT EVEN ON
THERE SIR -- SO.
CAN I GET A COMMITMENT YOU THAT
THAT COULD BE UPDATED RIGHT AWAY
BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY CRITICAL.
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING RIGHT TO THE
HEART OF WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
EXPLAIN TO YOU.
THE DROSE ACCOUNT.
DEALER RECORD OF SALE COUNT.
WHICH EVERY EVERY RESPONSIBLE
GUN OWNER AND GUN DEALER HAS TO
PAY INTO.
THAT MONEY SHOULD BE USED FOR
THESE TYPES OF SERVICES.
BUT I'VE BEEN HAVING TO USE THAT
GROWS MONEY TO PAY.
FOR APPS PROGRAM AND OTHER
THINGS AND THAT'S WHAT WAS SO
CRUCIAL THAT THIS YEAR GOVERNOR
NEWS RECOGNIZED YOU CAN'T KEEP
DOING THAT BECAUSE GUESS WHAT
HAPPENS.
YOU HAVE TO HOLD BACK ON SOME OF
THE SIX WHAT I WILL.
CONVEY TO YOU IS THAT ANY LAW
THAT NEEDED UPDATED HAS BEEN
UPDATED.
THAT -- DOCUMENT THAT YOU SHOULD
DO THAT MAKE SURE TWENTY SIXTEEN
I GUARANTEE YOU THAT THERE'S NO
WAY I CAN ENFORCE THE LAW
AGAINST SOMEONE IF I'VE GIVEN
THEM -- INACCURATEINFORMATION
BUT TO YOUR POINT.
WE WILL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN YOU PULL UP
A DOCUMENT THAT DEALS WITH
SOMETHING AS IMPORTANT AS BEING
RESPONSIBLE WITH OWNERSHIP OF A
WEAPON.
WE'LL TRY TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE IT'S UPDATE.
YEAH THE PORCH I I BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD NOT TO EMBARRASS OR OR
TO SHAME ANYBODY IT'S JUST THAT
THE FACT REMAINS.
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE AND THE INFORMATION
IS NOT AVAILABLE TO THEM AND
THEY'RE TOLD THAT IT'S AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
AND SO IT'S A FAIR THAT WE NEED
TO AMEND IKE RIGHT AWAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THAT YOUR POINT
IS ABSOLUTELY WILL TAKE CARE
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BOTH THANK THE MEASURE
OF THANK YOU DISTRICT ATTORNEY
JENNIFER COMING WE APPRECIATE IT
ALWAYS WHEN YOU COME AND SHARE
WITH US.
THE UPDATES IN THE PRIORITIES
AND WE'VE GOT TO DO AJAY'S BCP'S
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU REMEMBERING THANK YOU.
OKAY THAT BRINGS US TO THE NEXT
ITEM ON THE AGENDA -- WHICH IS
OUR SECOND ITEM.
WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH
IS A BUREAU FAR ARMS ARMED.
PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEMS
INVESTIGATIONS ASSOCIATED BUDGET
PROPOSAL SO YOU WE'VE ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT APPS ON SELF.
A VERY POPULAR TODAY -- WE HAVE
WITH US TODAY -- HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND OF
COURSE THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
AND IN THE IN.
THE LA -- SO OFFICES USE WELL SO
WE'LL HEAR FROM YOU FIRST YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CHRIS RYAN
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I THINK THE PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE
ON NOW IS THE APPS -- THE
FIREARMS WORKLOAD PROPOSAL --
THIS REQUEST IS FOR FORTY THREE
POSITIONS AND SIX POINT NINE
MILLION.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION ON GOING IN THE
DEALER RECORD OF SALE SPECIAL
ACCOUNT FUNDING.
THE REQUESTED FUNDING WILL
SUPPORT NINETEEN NEW POSITIONS
TWENTY FOUR POSITIONS CURRENTLY
IN THE BLANKET.
AND TWENTY POSITIONS WITH
LIMITED TERM FUNDING -- WHICH IS
EXPIRED -- THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS A
PERMANENT FUNDING SOLUTION TO
SUPPORT THE BUREAU'S CRITICAL
TIME SENSITIVE REGULATORY
WORKLOAD WHICH CAN NO LONGER BE
TEMPORARILY ABSORBED
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE CUT ANY OF THE COMMENTS.
OF ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE --
EMMA GENWORTH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IT'S TWO QUICK THINGS I
JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON THE FIRST --
IS A RECOMMENDATION FROM THE LA --
WHICH MISLI IS ABOUT TO TALK
ABOUT -- IT IS OUR
RECOMMENDATION FOR THAT DIRECTS
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REPORT ON
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS.
THE SHORTFALLS OF TO FIRE
RELATED SPECIAL FUNDS I JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT -- HER
RECOMMENDATION -- INCLUDES A
DECEMBER FIFTEENTH REPORTING
DATE.
AND WE DO HAVE CONCERNS OF THAT
DAY ONLY BECAUSE WE DON'T LIKE
TO PREEMPT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SO IN THESE TYPE OF REPORTING
ABOUT.
SHOULD GENERALLY FALL WITHIN
JANUARY'S TIME FRAME -- THE
SECOND IS REGARDING THE FUNDING
FOR THE APPS INVESTIGATION TEAMS --
THE PURPOSE BUDGET PROPOSES TO
SHIFT THE FUNDING FOR APPS TEAMS
TO THE GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE A
MORE STABLE FUND SOURCE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM.
AND TO ALLOW THE DEALERS RECORD
OF SALE ACCOUNT TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL FOR FEAR OF FIREARMS
WORKLOAD.
WE ARE AWARE OF THE FUNDING
DISCREPANCY THAT'S NOTED IN THE
STAFF COMMENTS AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO RID TO RESOLVE THIS
DISCREPANCY -- WE DID SEND AN
UPDATE A PROPOSAL TO STAFF LAST
WEEK A WHICH AT A HIGH LEVEL ALL
THIS TALK ABOUT -- THE PER
BUDGET WILL INCLUDE SEVENTEEN
AND A HALF MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO FULLY SUPPORT THE APPS TEAMS
THIS INCLUDES BOTH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AS
WELL AS ABLE FINANCE LETTER.
IT ALSO ELIMINATES THE
ASSOCIATIVE SPECIAL FUNDS
SUPPORT FOR THESE TEAMS -- AND
THEN ALSO MAKES ANOTHER SECTION
WITHIN THE BUREAU NOW SPLIT
FUNDED BETWEEN TWO DIFFERENT
SPECIAL FUNDS.
THE LEVEL FUNDING IS STILL THE
SAME IT'S JUST TWO DIFFERENT
SOURCES -- THIS UP IN A PROPOSAL
WE THINK ALLEVIATES THE FUNDING
DISCREPANCIES -- AND
ACCOMPLISHES THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL OF
PROVIDING GENERAL FUND
SPECIFICALLY FOR APPS THE BEST
ASIAN TEAMS WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY FOR FUNDING
ADDITIONAL BUREAU FARMS WORKLOAD --
LIKE I SAID WE HAVE SENT AN
UPDATED PROPOSAL AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATIONS FROM
KERR ANY COMMENTS FROM YELP.
I NEED TO LEAVE AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
SO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
THINK ACCURATELY SUMMER AS
SUMMARIZED TO THEIR UPDATED
PROPOSAL WE WOULD SAY BETWEEN
AND THE JANUARY OUR OUR MAJOR
CONCERN WITH THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL WAS THAT A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR THE
FIREARM SAFETY ENFORCEMENT FUND
THAT WAS FOR IN THE APPS
INVESTIGATIVE TEAMS.
WAS NOT.
BEING TAKEN AWAY ESSENTIALLY
WHICH WOULD MEAN THAT THE TEAM
HAD MORE FUNDING THAT THEY
REQUESTED.
THE PROPOSAL BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ADDRESSES THAT ISSUE
BY BASICALLY SHIFTING THOSE
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT OTHER
VERIFIERS WORKLOAD.
AND SO BECAUSE OF THAT WE ARE
GENERALLY AND SUPPORT AND WOULD
RECOMMEND ADOPTION OF THAT.
PART OF THE APRIL FINANCE LETTER
THAT YOU HAVE IDENTIFIED IN YOUR
AGENDA HIGHLIGHTS OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR SHIFTED
CENTRALLY WHICH WAS ROUGH
REFERENCE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
WE DO -- RECOMMEND A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT TO THAT BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT IS TOUCHING ON THE
FIREARMS SAFETY ACCOUNT AND IT
REALLY SHOULD.
THANKS IN THE SHOULD BE THE
FIREARM SAFETY AND ENFORCEMENT
FINE AND SO WITH THAT TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT THEN -- ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE SOUGHT BY THE
ADMINISTRATION FULLY FUNDING --
APPS THROUGH THE GENERAL FUND
AND KIND OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
OTHER PROGRAMS HAVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDING WHICH WOULD BE ACHIEVED
EVENTUALLY.
WE TO OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS --
THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION IS --
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO DIRECT
DOJ AND THE ADMINISTRATION
SEVERAL SUBMIT A REPORT NO LATER
THAN DECEMBER FIFTEENTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN ON
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS
MIGHT HAVE
ON THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE
FORCE.
OKAY COMMENTS FINANCE.
I JUST ADD THAT -- WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH IS COSTING
PROPOSAL MADE RECOMMENDATIONS LA
L..
HOW INTERESTING AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
WE'RE NOT RAISING CONCERNS WITH
THAT PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE FIVE
YEARS OF FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT
THE SYSTEM WE ARE RECOMMENDING
REJECTING THE ON GOING COMPONENT
WHICH IS WOULD BE TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION ON GOING -- COUPLE
REASONS FOR THAT BASICALLY
EVERYTHING THERE'S UNCERTAINTY
REGARDING THE LEVEL OF WORKLOAD
ON AN ONGOING BASIS BOTH BECAUSE
THIS NEW SYSTEM COULD CREATE
EFFICIENCIES BY -- TRADING OUT
THIRTY THIRTY EIGHT DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS -- FOR ONE COMBINED
SYSTEM AS WELL AS JUST LEVEL OF
WORK BUT IF THE CITY WITH
MAINTAINING.
THE SYSTEM MIGHT BE DIFFERENT
FROM THE LEVEL ASSOCIATED WITH
BUILDING A SYSTEM.
NEAR THE COMMENTS IN THE
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
BUSH'S THEY'VE THE MEMBER -- ANY --
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THAT
ITEM TO WILL BE HELD OVER.
UGH I FINAL ITEM IS THE MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM.
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES IS
HERE AS A AS WELL AS OTHERS AND
FOR THAT ITEM THIS ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX THIS REQUEST IS FOR TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND ON GOING TO SUPPORT PRE
POSITIONING ACTIVITIES THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF LEGISLATIVE
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS.
AND WITH ME I HAVE CHIEF MARSHAL
WHO CAN PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW AND
MORE INFORMATION ON THE MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM.
THANK YOU TARA FOR THE MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM -- IN CALIFORNIA FOR
NOT ONLY WILDLAND FIRES BUT ALL
HAZARD EMERGENCIES WITH THE B.
EARTHQUAKES FLOODS.
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS ANY TYPE OF
EMERGENCY UNITS FIRE RESCUE
RELATED.
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM DROPS THE
BOUNDARIES AND FIRE DEPARTMENTS
RESPOND TO ASSISTANCE.
THE REQUEST HERE IS FOR ONGOING
FUNDING FOR OUR PRE POSITIONING
SYSTEM.
AND THIS SYSTEM IS REQUESTED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIRE CHIEFS.
THROUGH THE OPERATIONAL AREA
COORDINATOR.
IT COMES FROM THE LOW LEVEL THE
LOWEST LEVEL FOR HELP.
AND THEN THE STATE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES WE FACILITATE
THOSE REQUESTS AND WE APPROVE --
FIREFIGHTERS FIRE ENGINES.
OTHER SPECIALIZE RESOURCES TO
STAFF UP AN AREA THAT COULD HAVE
A POTENTIAL FOR A LARGE SCALE
WILDLAND FIRE.
OR MAYBE A FLOOD OF THEIR THE
CONCEPT BEHIND THIS IS THROW
EVERYTHING AT IT.
BUT THE KITCHEN SINK AND THE
OTHER IN.
HE IN AN EFFORT TO KEEP THE FIRE
WILL -- SMALL.
AND BY UP STAFFING PRE
POSITIONING NEEDS RESOURCES WE
HAVE THE GREATEST CHANCE OF
SUCCESS.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT WE
HAVE THIS FUNDING IT HAS WORKED
WE HAVE PUT FIREFIGHTERS FIRE
ENGINES IN COMMUNITIES WHETHER
IT BE FOR A FIRE OR EXCUSE ME A
FIRE WEATHER EVENT OR A FLOOD
EVENT.
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND AGAIN IT'S THE
FIRE RESCUE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
THAT SUPPORTS THIS.
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
FACILITATES THESE REQUEST.
AND SINCE WE STARTED THIS
PROGRAM NOT QUITE A YEAR AGO
WE'VE HAD NINETY NINE PRE
POSITIONING REQUEST.
AND THIS IS AN INSURANCE POLICY.
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE THESE EXTRA
RESOURCES IN THEIR COMMUNITY IT
IS TRULY AN INSURANCE POLICY? TO
ALLOW -- OUR FIREFIGHTERS TO
JUMP ON A FIRE OR AN EMERGENCY
QUICKLY CONTAIN IT AND THEN BE
READY FOR THE NEXT ONE SO THAT'S
KIND OF AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
REQUEST AGAIN IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE HAVE THIS ONGOING FUNDING.
SO WE CAN CONTINUE THIS HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM I'M AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE VERY
QUICKLY -- I JUST WANNA TALK --
ABOUT THE FUNDING IN THE ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES FOR THE DEPARTMENT --
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUDGET
ACT -- YES RECEIVED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND -- IT WAS VERY
LIMITED TO PRE POSITIONING FOR
ONLY FIRE -- EVENTS -- SO AND I
KNOW D. G. R. FUNDING IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE CHALLENGING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THEY HAVE TO
MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA WHICH IS
WHY THERE WAS LIMITED FUNDING
EXPENDED THERE.
I THINK THEY'RE STILL SPENDING
OUT OF IT NOW -- IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT -- THE
FUNDING THAT WAS ORIGINALLY
PROVIDED THROUGH PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE HOW TO WRESTLING WHICH
ARE REQUIRED TO USE ON EQUIPMENT
AND TOOLS -- AND SO.
I THEN WENT SB NINE A ONE CAME
ALONG IT REVISE THAT PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW IT TO BE USED
ON ALL TYPES OF HAZARDS.
SO THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS ONLY
HAD JUST A FEW MONTHS TO START
SPENDING THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS DOWN FOR PRE POSITIONING
SPECIFICALLY.
HER ANY COMMENTS WELL L. JUST A
COUPLE OF QUICK COMMENTS. ONE IS
THIS IS A PROPOSAL THAT DIDN'T
COME WITH A BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL AND SO WE HAVE SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT THIS AS WELL AS
OTHER PROPOSALS AND THAT AND
THAT GENERAL -- CATEGORY OF
PROPOSALS THAT DIDN'T COME WITH
THE THAT DOCUMENTATION --
BASICALLY WE THINK IT'S MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
EVALUATE THOSE PROPOSALS.
SO WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO SUBMIT FUTURE
PROPOSALS THEIR SUBSTANTIVE LIKE
THIS -- ONE WITH BUDGET CHAIN
PROPOSALS THE SECOND JUST
SPECIFICALLY ON THE PRE
POSITIONING -- WE HAD JUST NOTED
THAT IT'S UNCLEAR EXACTLY WHAT
THE ON GOING LEVEL OF RESOURCES
WILL BE NEEDED AS FINANCE
INDICATED -- THERE IT'S
CERTAINLY THIS IS A BREAK A VERY
VERY NEW PROGRAM AND THE LAST
TWO YEARS SPENDING BEEN PROVIDED
THERE BEEN SOME REASONS WHY IT'S
TAKING A LITTLE BIT LONGER TO
GET UP.
AND RUNNING BUT IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN ONLY ABOUT FOUR MILLION
HAS BEEN EXPENDED OUT OF THAT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
AND THEN THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONLY ABOUT
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION HAS BEEN
EXPENDED SO FAR CERTAINLY THEY
MAKE THEY MAY NEED QUITE A BIT
MORE THAN THAT ON AN ONGOING
BASIS IT'S JUST VERY DIFFICULT
THE TALENT SO.
WE JUST WANTED TO FLAG THAT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE OKAY.
IN A CART QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
YES THE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU I PERSONAL ME SAY THIS
IS A VERY NECESSARY FUNDING IN
THE FORTIES CAME WITH A BIT MORE
LAST YEAR WITH WHAT THEY HAD.
REQUESTED AND I THINK WE SHOULD
TAKE THIS VERY SERIOUSLY THE
CHALLENGE THOUGH.
IN OUR BUDGETING PROCESS IS
PUTTING A BLOCK OF MONEY THERE
THAT'S WELL INTENDED.
AND THEN BEING ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT WAS USED FOR
AND THEN HOW THAT USE HELP SAYS
PREDICTS.
IN THE FUTURE.
AND I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AVAILABLE THAT'S ONE THING I
THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS REQUEST
REALLY IS.
BUT THEN TO GET KIND OF REPORTS
BACK ON DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE
OF WHERE TO PRE POSITION AND
WHAT WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS WERE.
I CAN AND WHAT HAPPENED.
NOT IN A WAY [inaudible] TO
OBVIOUSLY BE ABLE TO PREDICT THE
FUTURE BUT TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW IT WAS USED TO
THAT AS THESE COMES THROUGH THAT
WE CAN THEN.
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF THE
DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE TO
SPEND THAT MONEY AND TO USE THAT
MONEY.
I WOULD HATE FOR US TO BE.
PUTTING THIS MONEY ASIDE IN THE
DOWNLINE GET CRITICIZED FOR ITS
AVAILABILITY.
WHEN IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW IT
ULTIMATELY GETS USED BUT I THINK
IF WE LOOK AT IT AS AN
INVESTMENT?
IN PUBLIC SAFETY AND IN THE
PROTECTION THAT IT REPRESENTS
AND THEN BE ABLE TO TIE.
AND SOMETIMES WE MAY HAVE SPENT
SOME MONEY.
AND IT DIDN'T TURN OUT TO HAVE
BEEN NEEDED THAT'S NOT A BAD
THING THAT'S PROBABLY A GOOD
THING.
BECAUSE THAT MEANT THERE WAS NOT
NECESSARILY DISASTER OR THE
DISASTER I'M HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE
ABLE TO BUILD SOME CASES WHERE
WE SHOULD THE DESK DISASTER WAS
AVERTED.
WHERE IF FIRE EQUIPMENT OR
MERGED EQUIPMENT IS ABLE TO
SOLVE A PROBLEM EARLY ON?
THEN MAYBE WE WON'T SEE SOME OF
THESE HUGE CORPORATIONS THAT.
HAVE ENDED UP BECAUSE THE
RESOURCES WEREN'T ABLE TO BE
THERE.
I'M NOT SURE HOW WE ARTICULATE
THAT OR HOW WE BUILD THAT INTO.
BUDGET LANGUAGE WHICH IS REALLY
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SO HAVING A FUND AVAILABLE I
DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH OF A
PROBLEM FOR IT BUT BEING ABLE TO
LOOK AND AND UNDERSTAND HOW IT
WAS GETTING USED AS AS MAYBE A
PREDICTOR IN OVERTIME WE'LL
LEARN MORE.
AS A PREDICTOR FOR HOW IT MIGHT
BE USED AND MIGHT BE BETTER USE
THAT'S A CONVERSATION I THINK
THAT.
VERY HELPFUL AND VERY USEFUL SO
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD TOOL.
BUT I THINK WE ALL NEED TO LEARN
HOW TO USE IT WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS ARE AND THEN HOW TO
KEEP MAKING SURE.
THAT WE CAN BELIEVE SOME MONEY
AVAILABLE WHICH IN GOVERNMENT
PARLANCE IS A BIT OF A SCARY
THING THEY'RE LEAVING MONEY
AVAILABLE.
HIGHLY.
EASILY TARGETED FOR CRITICISM.
BUT FOR US TO THEN BE ABLE TO GO
BACK OKAY THIS IS HOW IT WAS
USED THESE ARE THE BENEFITS THAT
WE SAW FROM IT -- ALLOWS US TO
KIND OF KEEP THIS PROGRAM GOING.
DIFFICULT THING POTENTIALLY THE
THREAD BUT I THINK ULTIMATELY
VERY IMPORTANT SO I PREACH
PREACHY THE PRESENTATION I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS EARLY
DAYS.
IN THIS AND THAT WERE JUST
PUTTING MONEY OUT THERE BUT I
FOR ONE WAS SUPPORT OF LAST YEAR
OF THEM.
OF THE REQUEST FOR THE FOR THE
FIRE CHIEFS WAS WE ASK THEM.
WHAT WOULD YOU NEED TO HELP US
PROVIDE SOME OF THESE AND THEY
SAID HER MILLION DOLLARS?
LESS PRE POSITION LETTERS USE
THAT PREDICTIVE TOOLS THAT ARE
OUT THERE THERE'S NO GUARANTEE
OF WHAT THAT GETS USED FOR BUT I
THINK.
IF WELL SPENT WE CAN TRACK THE
BENEFIT AND WE CAN SEE THE
INVESTMENT.
IN BEING ABLE.
TO ADDRESS ISSUES BEFORE THEY
COME BACK IT'S NOT ALWAYS GOING
TO WORK UNFORTUNATELY BUT OFTEN
IT MIGHT.
SO I'M NOT SURE HOW WE DO THAT
BUT I THINK THAT'S A WORTHY
INQUIRY AND SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY KEEP TRACK OF
OKAY.
IN THE COMMENTS ON THAT.
I TOTALLY AGREE THAT -- IT IS AN
INVESTMENT I CALLED IT AN
INSURANCE POLICY.
IT IS AN INVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BY BEING ABLE -- TO
POSITION -- MORE RESOURCES TO
HAVE THAT AVAILABILITY WE DO
HAVE SOME IT SUCCESS STORIES
THAT WE CAN BRING BACK IN AND
SHARE WITH YOU.
AND I THINK THE PROBLEM
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AS WE DON'T
HAVE THAT CRYSTAL BALL.
AND YOU KNOW WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT THE STORIES THAT WE CAN TELL
BY BEING ABLE TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN A FIRE CHEESE BACK
POCKET IN A COMMUNITY THAT'S
FACING CRITICAL FIRE DANGER.
IN THE HEAT OF THE SUMMER -- YOU
KNOW WE WE CAN TELL THAT STORY
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO RESPOND SO
MANY MORE UNITS WE WERE ABLE TO
CONTAIN THE FIRE AT THIS SIZE.
AND WE CAN ACTUALLY RUN SOME
PREDICTIVE -- MODELING ON WHAT
THE FIRE WOULD HAVE DONE IF
THERE WAS NO ACTION TAKEN ON IT
SO I THINK WE CAN TELL THE STORY.
AND I THINK YOU'LL BE QUITE
IMPRESSED ABOUT HOW THIS PROGRAM
IS WORKING IN THE SUCCESS THAT
IT REALLY IS.
BUT IT IS AN INVESTMENT AS YOU
SAID.
RIGHT AND DECISIONS THAT GET
MADE BASED ON SOME OF THE
PREDICTIVE TOOLS ABOUT WHETHER
WIND PATTERNS HUMIDITY.
AND EVEN THOUGH SOMETHING DIDN'T
START BUT THAT'S WHY WAS THAT
DECISION MADE AND I THINK THAT
REALLY HELPS US BUT YET THERE
THERE ARE GOOD EXAMPLES.
ANY THAT WE SEEN OF ALL THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS. FOR EXAMPLE
I'VE SEEN AREAS WHERE THERE'S
BEEN A LARGE FIRE AND AIR ASSETS
THERE AND THEN A SMALL FIRE WILL
WILL START.
AND THEN BABY AND THEIR THEIR
ASSET GETS.
RE DIRECTED SOLVES THAT SMALL
PROBLEM AND THEN BACK TO THE BIG
PROBLEM.
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF HAVING
EQUIPMENT NEARBY.
AND USING IT EFFECTIVELY AND NOT
LETTING SOMETHING SMALL GET OUT
OF HAND SO I THINK WE CAN FIND
THOSE BUT I THINK THAT'S HOW WE
NEED THE TO BUILD THE CASE.
TALK ABOUT THIS PROGRAM AND BE
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT THE BENEFITS
OTHERWISE THAT MONEY SITTING
THERE THAT COULD OTHERWISE BE
PUT TO OTHER USE.
MIGHT BE TOO TEMPTING. TO
EVENTUALLY SWEEP AWAY AND I
DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT HAPPEN SO
I THINK WE HAVE TO CONTINUE.
THIS EXACT CONVERSATION AND AND
LOOK TO SOME STORES LOOK TO SOME
EXAMPLES OF HOW IT'S WORK I
THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
YES SIR OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I THINK AT I I I AGREE
WITH OUR OUR MRS STONE CLEARLY
THIS IS SOMETHING WITH WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO AT SOME
LEVEL -- BECAUSE I AT WE ARE.
COSTLY PLANNING FOR WHAT WE
THINK IS THE NEW NORMAL NOW WE
HOPE NOT BUT UP THE THE FIRES
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE OTHER
DISASTERS AND THE FLOODS IN THE
YOU NAME IT ALL THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS.
ARE REALLY ISSUES THAT WE FACE
NOW THAT WE DIDN'T THINK WE'D
HAVE TO FACE BEFORE.
WE'VE GOTTEN SMARTER IN SOME
AREAS YOU KNOW I COULDN'T
REMEMBER THE SAN DIEGO FIRE
WHERE.
PEOPLE SPENT.
DAYS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHO
WAS IN CHARGE OF A PLANE.
OF THE NOBODY KNEW WHO'S WHO
COULD GET A PLANE TO TO
BASICALLY PUT THE FIRE OUT WHICH
IS ABSOLUTELY INSANE.
AND SO FORTUNATELY AS A SAID NOW
I LOOK AND I SEE THE PLANES ARE
MOVING BECAUSE THEY GOT IT AND
UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE AND
AND AND THEY'RE NOT SITTING
AROUND DEBATING WITH A NOT IT'S
THE MILITARY OR ITS IS THIS OR
THAT AND IT WAS JUST THE MOST
FRUSTRATING THING IT'S IN SAN
DIEGO WE HAD A FIRE AND I THINK
WAS. TWO THOUSAND SEVEN OR
WHATEVER IT WAS THAT OF THEY CAN
FIGURE OUT WHO'S IN CHARGE OF
PLANES THAT THAT THEY COULD GET
THE WATER FOR TO FLY VER THE OF
THE FIRES AND SO I I SEE THE
COORDINATION.
THE BETTER COORDINATION IT'S
THERE AND I KNOW WE'VE DONE SOME
COORDINATION WITH THINGS OF THE
UNIVERSITY AND ALL THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS WITH OUR SAID
UNDERSTANDING AND MAPPING AND
YOU KNOW THAT KIND OF STUFF.
SO I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE
NEED TO DO WE JUST NEED TO TELL
BETTER STORY PROBABLY BE MORE.
DETAIL ABOUT THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WE DO BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT -- THAT WE PREVENT --
AS MUCH AS WELL AS RESPOND TO
ISSUES THAT OF THE YEAR AND I
THINK -- IF IF WE CAN.
TELL THAT STORY THE PUBLIC
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY THESE
RESOURCES NEED TO BE IN A
CERTAIN PLACE THAT'S TO BE USED
AS WELL AS TO SPECIFY WHAT THEY
USES.
FOR SORT OF IS SITTING THERE
LIKE IN A BANK OF EMERGENCY BANK
FEEL IS NOT BE IT'S JUST FOR
PEOPLE TO USE WHEN THEY GET
READY TO USE IT BUT IT.
ACTUALLY DOES SOMETHING OF THAT
WE THINK IS PREVENTIVE WAR
RESPONSE THIS YOURSELF HOPEFULLY
WILL WORK ON SOME OF THAT AS WE
TALK ABOUT HOW WE GOING.
TO DO THIS FINE AND IF YOU HAVE
ANY INNOVATIVE WAYS AND OTHERS
PLEASE LET US KNOW IT BECOMES
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THIS AND
THAT WE DO IT RIGHT.
YEAH.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
ANYONE FROM THE AUDIENCE YES.
TAKE IN [inaudible]
EIGHT THE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
MY NAME IS MIKE LAUGHLIN I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION I'M FIRE CHIEF --
LOCALLY WITH CONSUMERS FIRE NO
GROW WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY IN -- DISCUSSING THE
SUPPORT TOPIC AND MAKE A REALLY
ECHO.
ALL OF THE COMMENTS HERE TODAY
THAT WE NEED TO YOU KNOW THAT.
TWENTY FIVE MILLION STARTED OUT
AS A HUNDRED MILLION I WAS A BIT
ARBITRARY SECOND WE TOOK A
STRIKE TEAM IN A TEXT NUMBER OF
DOLLARS PER DAY WE PRE DEPLOY X.
NUMBER DURING THE COURSE OF A
YEAR.
WHAT WOULD THE COST BE IN ITS IT
WAS FROM A STARTING PLACE WE'RE
CONTINUING TO LEARN?
EACH INCIDENT EACH DAY EACH
WEATHER EVENT -- CONSUMING TO
LEARN AND GROW -- WERE COULD YOU
YOU COULD EXPAND THE PROBLEM OR
THE EXPAND THE PROGRAM TO NOT
JUST BE FOR WILD FIRE BUT IT
COULD BE FOR THE WEATHER MODESTY
DOES A GREAT EXAMPLE FOLLOWING
THE THOMAS FIRE.
IN LATE -- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
POTENTIAL FOR CIVIL UNREST AMONG
OTHER THINGS SO MAKING IT AN ALL
RISK PROGRAM I COULD AGREE WITH
YOU MORE HILLY MEMBER STONE AND
THAT THE KEY TO THIS IS HAVING.
THE DATA LET'S BE ABLE TO
QUANTIFY WHAT WE'RE DOING THE
SHOW THE IMPACTS AND REALLY OUR
GOALIS THIS PROGRAM WILL BE THE
THINGS THAT WE NEVER HEAR ABOUT
BECAUSE WE HAD RESOURCE IN PLACE
THAT.
THAT NEW THAT FIRE WASN'T EVEN
NEWS OR THAT'S THE GOAL OF THIS
PROGRAM SO HOW DO WE PROVE.
A NEGATIVE AND I THINK WORKING
CLOSELY BETWEEN CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS FIRE SCOPE CALLOW YES AND
CHIEF MARSHALL WE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO IT SO SO THANK YOU
FOR THIS OF THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTED OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA
FIRE TO USE WE FULLY SUPPORT.
AND WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO HELP
FOR HERE.
THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY THAT THAT CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA FOR TODAY SO ONE THANK
EVERYONE FOR COMING THE MEETING
IS ADJOURNED UNTIL.
SOMETIME IN APRIL NEW THE IN.
THE TWENTY SECOND OF APRIL WOW
WHOLE WEEK OFF.
GO TO SPRING BREAK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH